to hi everybody it's Monday it is a
beautiful day out here in Los Angeles
not a cloud in sight in fact
that's right
hope everyone had a uh Charmed beautiful
weekend
we are back to slave away
but not us you guys are but we're here
to make to you know
we we like what we do right guys we're
not slaves yes sir
geez you had to say it like that
are you trying to sound like something
I like we're not happy okay but we are
happy thank you baby nice to hear from
you thank you
but we're here to help you all get
through the week you know what I mean I
I know what it is
we're gonna have a great week guys I'm
telling you what just ignore the
soul-crushing pain
that you feel is sitting at a desk
every day
just listen to my voice
forget it all
we got a good show here today actually
we're gonna hear from a celebrity
calling in that's right it's Mr
rectangle himself
I'm squaring myself off I wasn't Square
myself upward already
what's his fullness what's his like
stage name
Sean is just Sean what is like
McDonald's
more like seal yo you a fan of Sean yes
Sean that'd be the most confusing name
ever just Sean so he's calling it at two
times Sean Stevens Sean Stevens music on
Tick Tock check him out John Stevens
that's my man yeah he is my favorite
artist right now I'm very much looking
forward he's doing incredible things yes
avant-garde things yes he's pushing I
can feel it in my holes
we should play that for him Zach and
what do you think about this verse
um suggestion we have got
um all kinds of good stuff to talk about
we've got uh oh yeah Russell Brand
threat or well he sent me legal notices
dude
I tweeted about but nobody cared I swear
to God Elon Musk was
yeah you got suppressed bro I think I've
never been suppressed on Twitter until
that I came took over I talked so much
the king of suppression talks so much
about Andrew Tate pointing out the
Matrix yet
here we are jacked it I think it makes
sense jacked in apparently the Matrix is
trying to stop Andrew Tate but I can't
get him off my timeline and here's
Russell Brand trying to stop my free
speech and I can't get a like
unbelievable make it make sense please I
thought it was free speech I did too
there Ninja
um
how many likes did it end up getting
because I expected that to get likes
didn't you okay yeah and when I first
posted it it was it was getting a lot of
likes it was completely stagnant for
like three hours it was just zero
nothing yeah I like it oh fourteen
thousand I guess we're not producing a
little bit but dude it was a 2K for four
hours I'm sure of it it's bizarre
because it's pretty I mean listen the
story itself is pretty weird like he
claimed our he did two claims on
our episode
first was this one doesn't even make
sense the fifth bit which is apparently
some kind of stand-up it's like not in
the show period
no no it is it was the it was the BBC
like radio
show they like the one where he was
talking about how he exposed himself yes
he claimed that yes
yeah no and so what it is is that's
clever so nobody the best bits of their
radio show were like collected into a
album I don't I'm sure it didn't get
like a physical release but like on
Spotify and apple music and stuff
there's like
an album of the best bits including when
he was talking about yeah that's one of
the best bits bragging about whipping
his dick out I'm glad that made the uh
yeah it's one of the best bits
so yeah that that got claimed but that's
what that was and then his new video the
so dot dot dot
also claimed
um how pathetic is that and like
we've talked about Russell Brand I've
never been claimed by
it just seems a little weird like
obviously party Hugo's like oh it's
probably automated but two different
claims both by Russell Brand
on our video
and I'm never claimed by these goons by
these types of guys you know what I mean
because they're this is their whole
thing like I'm free speech
which is you know commendable that they
don't but here comes Russell Brand with
a double claim I thought coffee
comedy should be like talking to lawyers
and bro you're probably gonna go to
jail there's like a good chance he's
gonna go to jail
I'm gonna need a lot more money than the
revenue from this video to pay that
up they should throw her under the
God This coffee's insane people are
asking what creamer is this
creamer it's crazy it's like um uh the
uh K-Cup it comes that mixed already
it's mixed already yeah
that's Heavenly can you show it yeah let
me grab it I like my coffee dark I
didn't know this was a K-Cup because we
have a K-Cup thing and I hate the coffee
it always Cooks at home
everybody's saying follow Olivia Ethan
what on the Twitter account this is just
like a a dummy I follow Olivia duh of
course this is just like a dummy uh
Twitter account this isn't actually
Ethan's real account that we're logged
into here yeah this is just oh I see
because it's suggesting her on the side
oh I see oh I see yeah we just use this
for a show I follow all three of these
people
Ethan has taste yeah come on I got you I
got you thank you girl
um this is a coffee for anyone who's one
let me see that that Ethan's been
recommending pull it back a little bit
it's out of focus I've been hitting that
too I don't even literally yeah
one step latte
okay I need to buy those at home yes
holy man it's crazy hard
it's like candy but you know it tastes
so good
um
so yeah he claimed us I made this video
but or maybe the Tweet was
a little provocative but I mean what
what in it isn't true
I said alleged rapist Russell Brand
doesn't like free speech when it's about
him delete the hateful tweet in question
he used his new video addressing his r
word allegations to claim our podcast
about him what a hypocritical loser and
by loser I mean our weirdest
allegedly of course but read the article
not much room for doubt I you know I
still see people defending him and it's
like you oh you haven't read the article
yeah totally they go oh it's so thin
they go the case against him is so thin
I says
I'm not gonna read it is that they just
say the same thing they did
it's incredible they don't they don't
look they just say that it's so thin
I I shouldn't say it I'm gonna
like um
since I'm on the topic I'll pull up this
this clip was was pretty interesting
oh by the way before I do that guys we
don't have sponsors this whole week
taking a fat L on that
go by the way I want to remind you guys
about Classics Teddy fresh
Classics it's up on the website it's
Evergreen we're trying to keep them
stocked up and what we've done is we've
been in the laboratory we've worked with
our partners we've reduced it to only
the essentials leaving only the most
luxurious beautiful fabric our beautiful
patented engineered fit and what you get
is the absolute bet and also we've eaten
significantly into our margin too and so
what we've done here is brought you the
best price possible
for the best clothing possible like for
example classic hoodie best the best
clothing possible it is
it is the best clothing possible the
best sixty dollars
um
three pack of tube socks 27 dollars
women's hoodie sixty dollars
some of these get crazy down here wait
what the best what
they're crazy
crazy deals hold on I don't think no
prices are right I think someone
up the prices
yeah these prices are not right
I gotta text someone
what
yo this is crazy hold on one sec this is
up
the owners have wanted to go got gone
out of the mines
oh
I mean we worked so hard on like to
perfecting his prices
this is insane this is effed up man it's
kind of making me angry
we'll figure it out
insane
that's right the prices are so low that
the owner is upset they're like he's
Furious apparently someone back there
was like these prices don't make any
sense we are losing money yeah you've
seen those kind of commercial Finance
says no we must put the prices back
how does this happen though this isn't
cool at all quick before they fix it
pay more pay more quick before they fix
it oh pay more yeah yeah they're paying
more that's what I'm not happy about oh
okay
hold on
yeah hold on guys buying that stuff all
right well he takes care of that yes
I'll play I'm gonna get him to fix it
and then I'm gonna plug it again set a
timer and buy it tomorrow some of these
are right I think let me see some of the
prices are right
but let's go ahead and just wait
so we know for sure
yeah I was looking at these and I was
like wait this doesn't seem that
I'm gonna we can do better than this
all right thanks for that thank you to
our sponsor
imagine that was a real paid sponsor
jeez I'm like wait nobody buy this
God
uh uh somebody is sponsoring us uh
why did we say this g-i-s-e Jizzy
Gizzy
is it Jizzy how are they sponsoring us
uh with a hundred uh ARS
Argentinian money RF all right thank you
[Applause]
rolling in the aars what's ARS
enal by the way is anyone listening
what's ARS I just said Argentina oh I
couldn't hear you no
how much they give us a hundred oh
that's damn dude thank you bro that's 29
cents it's 29 cents on today's open
market
I love that you can
and I appreciate that I'm not I'm not
scoffing I mean every you know what I
mean 29 cents is every bit count thank
you thank you I have more just feel bad
about probably butchering the
pronunciation and the name there
all right anyway let's move on so
um let me pull up this clip of this
woman defending
Russell Brand there's a
it's absolutely insane it's in the UK
and um
I don't know anything about this network
I guess it's a conservative Network
so she's trying to play
the team game I guess
and this guy you can tell which one has
read the article and which one hasn't
I'll put it that way
take a look at these
from what I understand uh both of these
hosts are uh conservative well one read
the article right and God bless him for
that
oh and then she even admits he goes did
you even like watch the documentary or
read the article she goes no I didn't
have to all right
good how dumb are you I'm not gonna read
it right
and watch this I've talked about um
because what Jonathan Ashworth is
referring to is your Tweet Beverly
Turner at the weekend when you said
about
um what's his name you are being
attacked establishment need you don't
know what to do with the fact you have
six million subscribers 6.5 and generate
autonomous name and original content you
are welcome on my GB new show anytime at
it's my show too we are mainstream media
but we are not established about him
let's be honest but we are not
establishing we do there's a difference
keep going this proves you're winning
you're a hero
she says he's a hero shameful it's not
that is shameful that is shameful you
have dismissed in one tweet a four-year
investigation by the Sunday Times the
times and channel Porters contemptuously
the mainstream media dumb ass I mean
these conservatives they're like rushing
to defend a raid best dude
they're like getting in line
they're like go ahead he's innocent
he's our hero
all right your turn he's a hero
what the I see someone in chat
saying that this uh network is like
Britain's uh Fox News essentially well I
mean listen
I'd love to see someone like this guy on
Fox News because he he's hitting it
right on the money man he's complaining
to being groomed by this man two women
have said they were raped and there are
more and more cases come inside and you
say you're a hero don't you think before
you say something
don't you think before you say he's a
hero you should establish whether these
very serious allegations are true or
read the article well before what else
to that before I tweeted that I had
spoken to several sources close to Brand
most of the times had you spoken because
those four women good out good question
I was confident that there is no smoking
gun in this regard right I remain
confident There's No Smoking Gun there's
text messages dude
there's and rape kits there's rape
kits yeah is that is that I don't get
much more smoking than that
what the are you talking about
like I at this point we're in such a
like post-fact world I mean it doesn't
get any clearer than this one man
There's No Smoking Gun what the are
you saying he's literally apologizing
he's like I'm sorry I raped you
in so many words there's a text of him
saying that she's like nah
I don't buy it he's a hero he's super
funny
you're tripping someone that funny
couldn't do something that bad
I don't buy it not that funny by the way
Elle if that is what they've got after
four years
investigation by the Times newspaper and
channel four those four flimsy
allegations from women who choose again
she goes flimsy and then she admits and
it's soon that she didn't even read it
Anonymous so there is nobody that can
counter their version of events there's
nobody who can say Anonymous they're
that again
and this is the thing every year
for these women every year there are 1.1
million people who are sexually
assaulted in this country newspapers
it's literally it's it's the script they
do it every time the same thing this
takes away from real victims
man if you only read the article like
it's not asking so much you are putting
your face on the news and defending a
rapist just read it first man these are
words coming out of your mouth
this is this is a hot New Meme format
huh
I love it Russell Brand Defenders when
you ask if they actually read the
article
oh man
I used to I used to with King of
Queens did you yeah I watched we were
talking about it earlier I did watch it
a little bit back then but I used to
just like kind of bounce around all the
sitcoms
I will catch an episode yeah if there
was nothing on exactly but he it all
fell apart when he became friends with
Adam and
like with most comedians maybe friend
Adam Sandler and then just they get a
fat paycheck and you're on they get all
of a sudden you're a mall cop exactly
Paul Blart
man used to be the King of Queens now
you're Paul Blart
you probably you're the King of Queens
man you probably got like 100 million
for that movie though I'm sure it's Adam
it's good man takes care of his friends
I'd like to know him I'll be a
I'll go play a gigolo whatever you need
me to do
what do you need to do Adam
you need to like
you want me to play like a movie where I
play like my twin sister and my mom
yes I'll do it man be epic and
50 million I'll do it
I will suck my own dick on camera
you'll see it all man just pay me that's
funny Crowder almost got that much money
right
you need to even offer to suck his own
dick
it shows dick to a lot of people
until
the city involved and then suddenly it's
all
up to not be sexually offensive
sexually assaulted oh well that's
something that's so refreshing of her to
give people lend them that right
everybody has that right of course and
this is a brave stance for this network
apparently what is her name I mean I
hope that she like gets laughed off of
British television forever I mean this
is just
this is crazy I said it at the very
beginning but I didn't care I'm gonna go
back and find it my heart goes out of
them this happens every single day of
sympathy in this statement on Twitter
for these four women who I would argue
none of them know each other it's a very
big thing to go public
and you say this is
allegedly raping and she says
let me tell you why he's winning he's
winning because he is a man who
generates his own content
he's a content creator he's a YouTuber
okay when as a content creator ever
sexually assaulted someone they'll make
me even one Google that even once
somebody who makes content for a lot
okay let me tell you why he's a hero and
why he could never be a rapist
um he's a YouTuber
next
case dismissed what a you're on TV
lady you know that it's live
I love newspapers don't get me wrong I
love this industry that's more important
than these allocations why now why now
it's taken four years to this the year
before an election year how convenient
it's not even close to the election it's
like what does that mean why now
like three years ago I don't know lady
but she's seen what I've seen which is
80 000 views on his rumbler videos
that's a threat to the establishment I'm
scared
I'm sorry I'm trying to look up her name
but my Google isn't working for some
reason I've just restarted my computer
I'm doing everything you've been banned
you've been banned you bro I forgot to
mention she's chat GPT what if you go
Incognito does that work
uh yeah I've done I've literally you
tried different browser the internet
work or just yeah it works I could use
like Bing but Bing is I can't find
on Bing I don't know those are some Isis
videos
why haven't they gone to the police well
the allegations she had she went and got
a rape kids
like she's she's so openly so proudly
ignorant like just wrongly defending a
freaking rapist man I mean shout out I
guess what in a sense it's almost like
okay girl
he went all out and uh you know what I
mean all or nothing I like that no half
measures
and they're increasing in their number
and I guarantee to you this is going to
be
a huge investigation a huge story and
I'm astonished that you let to his
defense
content in the last three years
thank you but hold on this is good
Saturday morning
I love him he's actually doing great
I've even seen the dispatchers program
good for you man I'm I'm happy to see
that like an older guy too but not like
good ass words like that what's
her name Beverly Turner Beverly Turner
Beverly
I wish you wanted to be a roaster right
in the media let's come on Bev
Beverly Turner let's see
let's take a look at Beverly Turner
who's pro-rape actually it turns out
or no she's not pro-rape just for funny
dudes who she thinks she's been inspired
by
let's see Bev
if she's not getting in the media
I'm I'm not gonna be happy about this
let's see news
defends her tweet and support oh this is
one week ago did you what how did you
just support him a week ago this this
story's been out that long
yeah broke like last Tuesday or
something right
I guess she's fine
she's cool man
she's crushing it
love that for her anyway shout out to
him I thought that was great and equally
measured embarrassed for her I mean wow
that's nuts man
here's the Tweet okay
no this is her oh she's even been
she's also
oh she's the best this is just from two
months ago all the classics the Jewish
group criticizes uh Beverly Turner over
dangerous conspiracy theories Beverly
Turner retweeted that covet causes less
harm to certain ethnicities Asians and
Eskenazi Jews oh well that's oh that's
just that's okay Junior that's a
mainstream uh platform in the United
States of America oh what's the problem
yo RFK Jr's a leader in that and he said
that yeah
on video and then said that he never
said it the thing is he's also jacked
which is another thing yeah he's hot and
he's and he's rich in a Kennedy so you
should listen to him you know
um let's check out our girl Bev let's
see what she's up to we got Beverly
man imagine being this file she probably
has kids too I don't know
mommy did you have a good time defending
the rapist today
yes sweetheart
it was a tremendous day
now go run off and play
and don't forget your rape wisdom
I didn't know that my co-host was going
to do this today oh she got pissed at
him I knew we'd be discussing the topic
of course but I wasn't prepared for the
personal Onslaught which is why I look
completely off guard to fully understand
my position which is difficult to
articulate
please read this piece that I wrote
thanks
dude
why should I read your piece you didn't
read I'm not going to read it I'm not
reading your I'm not gonna read it
you
on TV news we put free speech first nice
even when we disagree with each other
they furiously clashed over a tweet
which she called Russell Brand a hero
after an investigation
um she what wait she wanted me to watch
this
this encounter
oh no here here
I'm actually I'm really curious to know
what she had to say is Russell Brand the
victim of a media Witch Hunt asks Bev
Turner who hasn't looked at any of the
evidence yeah how would you know one way
or the other which she's just well
in the New World Order crimes especially
sex sexual ones there will not be
evidence presented only the jury will
decide on Vibes right talking about
burning the witch we'll do a consensus
on vibes
and of course everyone knows that
Russell Brand gives us a tremendous
non-rapy vibes
I believe in a society where we can
defend someone current character was
also being willing and able to condemn
historic illegal actions
what I don't know she didn't read it
wait no no hold on I
she believes in a society where we
convince someone's current character
yeah that stuff happened before it
doesn't matter that doesn't really so
that's what she's saying he may have
raped people then yeah but he's he had
he's a good guy he hasn't done it in a
while and he's a good guy now dude he
hasn't raped anyone in like three years
right
okay let's see this is I'm actually real
interested in this article apparently it
equates her okay complicated nuanced
issues require careful consideration not
hot-headed mud slinging all right let's
give it a let's go and that's why
following my tweet about Russell Brand
over the weekend I wanted to share this
longer article so I could explain
in more detail why I'm concerned about
the nature of the Scandal engulfing him
more importantly I wanted to set out
what I believe are some of the wider
implications
but before this make me make this
Crystal Clear
amongst this noise around a man who's
repeatedly admitted that he was very
very promiscuous yes we risk forgetting
that in the UK 1.1 million adults
experience essay no
this is like this is the Playbook
they're like well listen there's women
out there being R worded why aren't we
talking about each one of them right now
in the U.S 40 percent of women say that
they have experienced sexual violence
with 80 percent of female sexual so this
is really what is she like why is yeah
let's follow the logic here she goes
Russell Brand
has repeated to being very very
promiscuous so he slept with a lot of
women but then she goes
somehow
40 of women
have experienced sexual violence so
Russell Brand who slept with like a
thousand women
has never crossed the line with a single
one of them
he's the good I maybe my analysis isn't
perfect there well let's see what her
follow I need to see her next
uh I'm glad she got a really hinged
looking photo of him to uh tie it all
together
you know that's the way he looks
tragically these statistics are of
little interest to most people until a
famous person is involved oh my God then
it gets sufficiently spicy to make
headlines
I believe anybody who's been the victim
at SAR r r word deserves Justice
okay
I too no you don't
you've proven you don't
all too often they're denied the Justice
by a flawed system I believe women's
voice are too easily dismissed
that's what you're doing right now
is most significant when they are
ignored in the uh sexual offenses unit
of a police station however
excuse me
I also believe in society where we can
defend someone's current character who's
also being willing and able to condemn
historic illegal actions that's crazy
I've been accused of being hot off the
mark with my defense of brand on X
formerly Twitter I love how
you gotta suck She Gotta gliz up Eagle
on there a little bit
I feel like if you call Twitter X you're
like
you're a show
that's it if you call Twitter X you're
an Elon shell
you're An Enemy of the State
I'm kidding I don't know do you guys but
you guys don't say x do you no no it's
crazy right it's called Twitter nice try
dumbass I swear to God they're the only
people I see doing this are like
conservatives who are trying to yeah
they love it they love that it's they
love it it's X
uh brand on X prior to the details of
the allegation being made clear okay
let's wrap it up
you know
had you been arrested at that time I
would still have been suspicious of
vested interest that's awesome
so nothing could have happened but my
trepidation would have been more acute
however after speaking to several close
sources to both media outlets and brand
himself on Saturday morning and brand
himself oh okay he said he didn't do it
it was clear that although some of the
behavior being alleged is depraved each
instance is nothing more than he said
verse she said rape kit
you asked him
is she a journalist
is that her job I don't know through a
decade-long time lapse as usual there's
nuance
[Music]
obviously every human being deserves the
right to refuse sex oh thank you for
that or physical industry of any type
but this current trial by media is
grotesque
I've been urged to keep quiet stay out
of it I don't personally know Russell
Brand although I I call them up though
yeah he's a hero and I contacted him
why would I speak up that simple loyalty
no
that's the craziest reason to defend a
rapist
[Music]
okay this is crazy
I'm grateful
loyalty you say you don't even know him
I'm grateful to the emboldening
narrative he has provided millions of US
during the most tumultuous period of
modern history she doesn't she doesn't
know him but she can call him up and
she's extremely loyal to him but I don't
know him because he was anti-covet I
guess and that meant a lot to her yeah
bran has not been arrested oh my God
but you just said if he was arrested you
also wouldn't care
Maybe I'm Wrong to be cynical that a
Smoking Gun will be found
she still hasn't read the article she
hasn't no she hasn't it's obvious
I'm an idiot wow man done I wrote
a whole ass article about this
blah blah blah blah
I'm just I'm just going to read bits he
has a powerful group of similar Outcast
allies like Jordan Peterson Joe Rogan
Tucker Carlson and bandana Shiva I don't
know who that is oh new character
unlocked
exciting so unless you have followed
Bran's remarkable online journey to
expose corruption it's all too easy to
write him off as a rapist Turn the page
of the news and wait for the next
hilarity
oh my God I'm a
ah this is this is something so shout
out Bev Turner
who um supports women she said so in the
first paragraph
love that for her cool thank you guys
for following
love her
mm-hmm
also apologies to Bev for um
engineering covid not to affect my
people
I'll next time make sure gets us too
yeah just at least for Optics sake you
know what I mean I'll make sure um when
I go to school tonight for Yom Kippur
I'll uh atone for that tell them we got
to be more subtle next time when we plan
yeah a yeah a pandemic it's like dude we
can't we can't all not get it
oh wait I got it and all my did you get
attacked I did yes oh and presumably
millions and millions of Chinese people
probably more Chinese people got it then
than anybody else Americans by far
well we did they were way more stringent
on the lockdowns since then they've been
having crazy outbreaks yeah because they
didn't have anything and there's also
there's three times the population yeah
so it's probably safe probably like Bill
like a billion plus Chinese people that
got covered
this is great it's very good
we love it so much we love her
all right thank you
anyway yeah Russell claimed our so
he's a coward but then I was like I was
like oh he's a hypocrite and I was like
wait he's a rapist that's way worse when
I was writing the tweet
like Hypocrites not an insult he's a
rapist he wishes he was just a hypocrite
you know it's practically a compliment
to him
so
there it is
thank you everybody there it is
oh check it out so if he doesn't let you
profit off his content he's hindering
your free speech
um
profit off his content
okay
damn who you working for look at all the
shows it's so fun
so easy I'll take it off the screen take
it off the screen oh yeah okay can't
just
all right let's move on thank you
so that's that
let me see what Ela said about the
Plastics page
okay in the meantime because it's a lot
I'll take a look at the chat we just got
a one gifted member from Bethany thank
you Bethany appreciate that uh
[Applause]
there's a 30 Super Chat I'm trying to
get over to hey fam I'm home sick from
work can I get a hey girl from eth and
Olive to bring my soul back from the
depths of hell that it's currently in
thank you thank you oh my god hey girl
hi girlie I hope you're okay I hope you
feel better hi sorry you don't feel good
feel better
all right okay now here's that other
thing oh are you wanna you have
something you want to do no no go ahead
so you guys know I'm supposed to get a
tattoo
tomorrow live on the show not tomorrow
Wednesday right Wednesday thank you Dan
um and we've been listen obviously it's
my first tattoo and obviously the
meaning of it is needless to explain
extremely important to get a hey girl
from you and that was me I saw I'm not
gonna say who they are and please don't
try to find out because that's not what
this is about okay
I'm serious like don't please it's not
like that
um
but I found someone on Instagram that
was had really beautiful
um photorealistic
tattoos
in LA and that's what I wanted I wanted
something like that so
I reserved the day
I I sent him the money even for the you
know the nurse
he refunded me by the way so don't even
get angry about that
but it all kind of went sideways when
when was it yesterday I think it was
yesterday or Saturday
because I was yeah Saturday he wanted
first of all he wanted to just
figure it out when he got here and I was
like no
gotta have a lockdown tell me I need to
know exactly what's going to look like
before we
before I ever see a needle
and so he's like okay I got you I got
you we had a long conversation about
what I wanted I sent him a specific
picture that I really love of him that's
so sweet on his last day and he's
looking back like an angel and I just I
love it so much it's so meaningful to me
I sent him that photo I I talked to him
all about it and what I want it to look
like and this is what he sends me I
literally
I I think it's the worst tattoo I think
it's the worst tattoo I've ever seen in
my whole life I mean I was losing my
mind I was so excited to see it
look at this
he sent me a random looking
Yorkie looks what and a top hat
why is he wearing a top hat is he
attending his own funeral also who wears
the top at
and what's with the flowers
and then wait it gets even weirder a tux
you know a human being did you describe
him in a way like were you did you talk
about his no there's never a mess he was
a Regal dog let me read you verbatim
a he was a guy who looked good when he
cleaned up
it doesn't look like my dog at all what
the dude
I love this one for like 30 minutes
straight on Saturday morning I was like
crying it was surprised I was I've ever
seen
oh man
you know I I put a lot of effort into
communicating with him and sending
intimate photos of my beautiful animal
to him
he sent all these and he goes how do you
like it
I was trying to be nice I just said
I was nice I was too I was nice I said I
don't like the flowers let's just go
with the portrait also the dog doesn't
look like him can we just go with the
original photo please
thing about the clothes no I just said
just do the photo I was like I didn't
wanna
maybe you could switch up his outfit a
little bit straight up an episode of
curb I'm not even kidding let me read
this would be I sent him all the photos
I said this one is special to me we
could try to make it look like he's
turning back One Last Time to Say
Goodbye like maybe he's on a Rainbow
Bridge from heaven
because I assume that he's these people
are artists they're wonderful artists
they can do stuff like that right they
customize it they send it to me
I said
um I sent him a whole bunch more photos
can you guys do a okay yada yada
we talk about the price
I talked to him on the phone that's it I
guess that's all I said we talked about
it on the phone a bit
what the have you ever seen
something so ridiculous he's like no I'm
gonna give you the Dog Father instead
the Dog Father
you hit me with this bro
and then there's these ones again like I
guess it looks it's not my dog though no
that's not Shredder well look so let's
talk about the elephant in the room too
this very obviously is AI generated
that's the other thing we started to
realize is like this is just mid-year
once once you sent more like because
initially it was just the top of that
one right I sent these two or the two
the two right what gave everybody about
the second one there you guys pointed
out that uh go to the dog the dog father
real quick scroll up
uh that little tulip on the side there
you guys that'll look like a crack pipe
but this like
so AI it's not it doesn't look right
yeah so he put the he doesn't even edit
it he's like I'll put up the up
crap let's put the crack pipe in there
too right which like if you want to use
AI uh to like just come up with a bunch
of options to kind of decide on a
Direction I mean if you're up front
about that's what you're gonna do to
help plan it out I don't think that's a
problem but he didn't say that he just
sent this to you right he said
apparently they make it in Photoshop and
he's a and he they have to create the
art
no he must be using that new Photoshop
AI then right there right Photoshop does
have ai why does he have a bow he never
wore a bow in his life whose dog is that
it's not my dog
but yeah that's the thing too is like
the AIS side
you asked you sent him a photo I was
like I want this photo it's a tattoo
how does he wind up doing it and then
when I so when I was like bro what is
this like a photo of my dog you
know I sent you all these photos you
asked for and then here let me show you
[Laughter]
you guys have all the stuff I sent you
right like when he just showed up
massive
the massive photo my arm
uh yeah this one here it is here it is
I mean what the dude here I'm gonna
send it and WhatsApp you got it yeah I
got it so then I was like bro just use
the photo I sent you what what are you
doing oh no this is this came later
hold on
show me the one where it's just the
picture not with the frame not with the
frame uh here so
this guy's apparently reputable like
celebrities went there he's got like a
whole team I thought I was being scammed
and I went and like his address is I saw
on Google street maps like it's there
it's a real place right
um yeah no I'm sure I I don't doubt that
he's very talented at like executing on
the tattoo but this planning uh process
was uh
pretty botched yeah here so we go so
then he sends me this when I was like
just use the photo bro
what the
just a massive
it's so massive
I mean
it's kind of weird how it just kind of
Fades at the bottom doesn't look great I
mean I do love this photo it's so cute
but it's so big
you guys like this photo by the way
super flattering
I really notice the weight loss
and then I was like man I don't know
that looks kind of like you just
I'm not sure about that so then he said
I think you should just get the top hat
one at this point I think you gotta do
it it's full back
yeah don't no oh no okay which one don't
worry about it oh yeah no don't show
that one you don't and then he sent me
bro I swear to God then I said just use
the phone or then without I was like I
don't know if this is working and then
he sent me this
the is this
[Music]
it's a giant frame there's more frame
than dog it's a beautiful frame I mean
yeah maybe it's a specialty wow what is
this what a frame now yeah this one
definitely looks the most clip art I was
like bro you're just using clip art and
Ai and just stop trying I'm over it okay
I like it
cam sent this in our chat
cam comes up with some Banger memes just
for our group chat uh so funny it's so
funny cam show the ones you made using
mid-journey that looks identical okay I
made a made a bunch it's so easy to do
um they literally are identical this one
was quite good too this is I guess maybe
even cooler than what he said I don't
know here I did this with Yorkie
specifically right here
and then you can just mix it up with any
dog you like
all right pulling it up yeah
so these are ones that can't that's
crazy dude
so you just typed like tattoo of dog
with flowers and roses
um actually what I did was I took mid
Journey has this thing where you can
upload an image and it describes it for
you
and then it uh
you just type in what it described zero
yeah zero effort whatsoever so and did
you ask it to do it like a tattoo uh
hold on I'll show you actually what it
looks like
I mean here's other ones cam made of
another Yorkie
I guess if you're
I don't know man
so they tried to feed it a picture of
Shredder and it just gave him a generic
Yorkie I guess this is this is what it
looks like and I should say I never use
AI for my own uh photoshops on the show
too thank you of course not of course
not
so do me a favor take that picture of
Shredder
upload it and say hey make this into a
tattoo okay I'm curious but then he had
to give it he just put it in a top hat
you'd have to say that right
put it in a top hat in a tuxedo I think
they I just added a top head on its own
I'm afraid I can't do that look at some
creative Liberty true in a human with
shoulders he has human shoulders
why is there a child in the back of this
AI image how weird is that
why is there two kids Behind what the
dude ai's out of control man we need to
regulate this
so I don't know I'm I'm feeling pretty
sour about the whole thing oh this is
horrible look at this again
what the dude
it's a giant frame why is the frame so
big
it's crazy dude why such a huge frame it
doesn't make sense why would you send me
that
I thought I was like are you like a 15
year old scamming me right now
I don't know why it reminds me of like a
postage stamp
yeah you'll hear about to be sent here
the picture of his Shredder is like
super local
res too
so and then there was one more because I
I saw another artist that I liked and
they I guess specialize in doing pets
which I think is what I need to look up
next time it's just someone who does
pets specifically
and they had this really clever way of
just doing like
the head and then doing some kind of
outline on the bottom to make it look
I don't know cleaner and he just sent he
just cut out the body
and then
he just drew a line
who would say yes
who the would say yes to that
I was kind of speechless by the whole
thing I I mean this is my first
experience so
I'm somewhat a gaff aghast by all this I
was literally I remember waking up on
Saturday this is the first thing I saw I
had to like wipe my eyes and take a look
and I and I like nudge lean I'm like
please look at this am I high right now
what the is this I thought we were
missing some kind of context or
something I scrolled up and like Dan's
like I'm literally still crying from
this
someone says it had to be a troll I
promise you it's not a troll
I promise you it's not a troll we do a
little trolling it's called we doing
I promise
you know and he kept trying to convince
me he's like dude just let me show up
we'll do it in person it's gonna be
great I was like no dude I never
want to meet you
what if this guy's like a tate fan or
something I'd be like yo can I get a
tattoo of my grandma puts a top hat on
her yeah my grandma passed away can I
get him or real sure here's using a top
hat
excuse me I'm trying to honor my dead
grandma
gotcha yeah I'm trying to honor my dead
Grandma can you put her uh cadaver going
down a water slide
with a top hat and monocle
how did you find this guy
okay well not that it's your fault
Cameron because you just
sent it to me I don't think you you
weren't vouching for them and I know you
weren't but that's how I found a cam I
said I was like man how do I find and I
think cam you just looked up realistic
tattoo artists and sent me a bunch
exactly yeah and then I I just contacted
one and
that was it so it's not it's not at all
Cameron's fault at all you did not vouch
for them not your fault you were just
showing me how easy it was to find
people
and um
I just went with the first person who
answered and yeah I didn't expect them
to send all this
it's not your fault well in the end
we've we
didn't do it I wear yeah I don't even
know how to describe it
but now I'm kind of back to square one
and I'm not sure I think you should go
to the place that me and my parents
always go
do they I sent it to you your parents
get tatted yeah my mom not my dad do
they do pets yeah I the I sent you the
link to their Instagram and he literally
has one I don't want to pull it up
because then uh no I'll show that once I
get it and I'm happy you know what I
mean I'm not trying to ruin anybody's
business
wait let me see what you sent me I know
they do beautiful work I've seen a lot
of people now after this all happened
who specialize in pets dogs and cats
and so
because it needs to be it's my only
tattoo you know
please let us find you a genuine artist
please do I mean if y'all are someone or
know someone
that can do my grandma in a top hat and
a tuxedo
really looking in an open casket
please
are you working on that uh cam
uh working on what the top hat and
Tuxedo you run I wanted you to feed a
picture of Shredder yeah I'm trying to
figure out how to do that right now okay
one sec and then can you just do open
casket funeral of my grandma with a top
hat um
let me see that too actually you know
what hold on I got to show you what the
AI just came up with yeah
so did you you like disclosed
emotionally to this tattoo I told him I
was like my dog passed away a couple
years ago I'm devastated I loved him so
much uh-huh and then he goes I got you
fam and then he sent he says I got you
fam
and for those Reasons I'm out to me the
top hat one is terrible but the tuxedo
one is perfect
he sent two of them two of them yeah one
in a suit yeah I like them in a suit or
a talks I mean it's up to you about it
right yeah Shredder's clavicle
do you see what I sent I'll open it
right now looking good wait that's not
it doesn't look like a tattoo I try to
combine the two images it doesn't look a
lot more like Shredder though yeah
but it it did it in reverse
look like Shredder
looking good in that suit
man
so that was insane
I had a hard time getting over this it's
like yo the death of my dog was
traumatic enough now you got to do this
to me right
so he imagined these would be comforting
he's like what do you think he was
stubbed yeah he's really stoked he was
super into it
I want to live in that head
apparently he's busy too he's like we're
booked up all week you got to hit me
next time
um well I don't know
that thing else
kind of me up I'm not gonna lie
so
maybe there's a tattoo artist watching
who's good
are you friends with someone that's good
because the thing is I did want to do it
on the show
I thought that would be an interesting
angle
and then I was like imagine I got one
live and it was it was horrible and
it went horrible and I'm like yo what is
happening right now and we I get into a
thing with this guy on the line yeah
what happened to you that would be
insane that would be the craziest thing
ever
I'll look into him Olivia
I want to work with pets
oh here this one is odd in my late uh
dear grandmother who's
I sent him a picture of her and uh he
sent me this back thank you buddy
yeah she doesn't look this is a
completely it's cool that one's awesome
okay that one's fire yeah
all right Nana your AI game is better
than his
I don't even see any crack pipes or
anything I asked her to be in an open
casket but they just skipped that I
think they're like yeah
all right well
rectangular guys here oh here's cam
thank you Cam this is oh this is exactly
what I wanted thank you guys well this
is just an image though
this is weird as dude
a picture of my grandma with a top hat
and a open casket
wait why are all these old people
serving at the funerals yo the hand
looks good the hands are getting better
why is the top hat look so weird
statement piece
okay
well that's not what I'm here to do but
it's cool
they don't want to show the dead person
I guess
guess not okay well
let's try to uh
bleach our eyes and by talking to a
rectangular guy and not you know in a
good way like I believe not like throw
actual bleach in your eyes
I was confused by that concept at first
I bleach
I was like that sounds horrible right
throw bleach in your eyes clean them out
I can't yeah let's talk to them okay
Ethan I need to talk to my boy here
let's get uh let's get in the right mind
space yeah there you go let's get
rectangular real quick
ah all right I'm bringing them in
here we go
I am rectangular
[Music]
all right and Tech CEO Sean scared
welcome to the show ravagant
Extravaganza here he is Sean Evans Mr
rectangular himself
Stevens how are you today thanks for
calling in
I'm amazing now I appreciate it I
appreciate being here so tell me um a
little so you're you're ahead of a tech
company is that what you do for your day
job
yeah so a couple of different companies
one company streetprod.ca which is a
digital transformation agencies that's
kind of a tech company meets the
marketing company so we build apps and
we do artificial intelligence not mental
reality and also do marketing nice and
we also have uh what's called an
accelerator so we help businesses uh we
were at the beginning of their Tech
Journey get get funding get help Etc wow
so you're doing quick so you're you're a
successful businessman you would
describe yourself as
well what's the moment of success is
there any point where you know
um
you got seven digits easy right
okay if it's just seven digits
so I think 30 million I heard that
there's only 249
000 people in the world who have over 30
million in their bank account right now
how much
I just read this not 249
000. someone should look this up I mean
that's and so are you one of those
people
uh well if it's in my bank account no
but if it's just in general for like
right
and what are your thoughts uh you know
what's rectangular a dollar bill that's
true that's true and it's green and uh
Sean what what are your thoughts on
socialism
I'm kidding I'm kidding
we've had we've been having a lot of
conversations about socialism today and
as a capital uh as a capitalist Pig I
wanted to get your take and I mean that
thesis because I am also a capitalist
Pig
yeah well I'm Canadian so we we're kind
of our version of capitalism is a little
softer a little more socialist a little
bit left that's true you do the health
you do the health which is nice we like
the health insurance
no people don't we don't get health care
here and we just kind of wander around
bleed to death
right see what I do is I help people
move to Canada who have cool businesses
so that they can you know be looked
after Byers so have you always been a
musical how did this ambition come along
you're you're running these businesses
you're doing very well when did the urge
to become rectangular come from
uh to be honest I started uh I wanted to
be a musician so this job as a result of
not being able to pay my bills as a
musician so University went I mean
become a musician made records was doing
pretty good on College stations and
stuff and then you had kids and reality
set in and so the dream said we put on
the back burner and I had to go get this
dead-end job as a CEO and sort of build
a company and uh my kids were older and
uh I'm bored and I decided to start
recording and actually Kobe did the lot
for that because suddenly I'm at home
with the guitar again and I'm writing
again and now fast forward a whole bunch
of time and giddy up giddy up and so are
you are you the CEO or the owner CEO
just curious
uh owner CEO yeah okay and you have kids
how old are your kids
I have a 14 year old boy and a 17 year
old girl I cannot remember I'm the Dad
we don't remember their age it's tough
they're you know there's so many years
to remember how do they what do they
feel about your music are they fans
they're the only fans of matter I write
my music for them so I write music I
played for them and if they say it sucks
it goes in the garbage if they say it's
fire then it goes oh nice so they
dude I gotta say you have a beautiful
voice I mean Zach you vouch for that one
breakdown moment right you were kind of
losing your mind Zach's the guitarist
himself how you doing pleasure to be
speaking to you it's an honor to be
speaking with you
um yeah you on the rectangular section
like when you are the song when you get
into it I think it's the breakdown
section there's like this halftime feel
that is just Wicked let's play
cool yeah let's play it we can get his
thoughts even
don't worry when it comes out we're
gonna watch it don't worry about it
awesome
a lot of money on it tell me how much
tell me about it how long whoa
I bought this this box
right for 2.87 in the whole music video
is just this box that's it you know what
I'm saying that's what it means to be
rectangular isn't it
yeah
um you want to play attack
um we just dropped the full version in
uh the uh we should probably just play
it like really quietly this whole time
okay we can do that
just to just as a little background and
the the green hair is that part of the
music Persona how long have we been
doing the green imagery
oh man a very long time like 15 years
wow and I
it all kind of started with me just like
with a little bit of color like a little
bits and it you know just jumped the
shark eventually and now I've got
here
okay nice I love I mean green is Green's
The Color of Money is that a coincidence
it is the color it's got a lot of things
also color of the environment more its
color of frogs many frogs we love frogs
and it's the color of the environment
what do you mean by that
well uh we're a highly environmentally
orientated company so anytime
environment we do so that's I'm sort of
a crazy I would say a more
environmentalist than socialist as more
environmental we like that we like that
we'll take what we can get right people
there's a lot of radical communism in
our audience so if you can toss them a
bone they'll to satisfy their their urge
for
the blood of uh landlords and whatever
who else do you hate then Capital owners
sorry I stopped that
so what does it mean to be rectangular
we were listening to the words it says
I'm rectangular I have no holes
so are you
so so you're not a circle and you don't
have holes is that right
you know what the whole uh idea came out
of there's a there's a meme which I saw
on Tick Tock I think it was of a
comedian and I'm sorry I don't know the
name her name but throughout my head and
she's looking at this kid's you know box
that you put shapes into and she's sort
of reacting to the to the person putting
the shapes into the box and she's
freaking out and I'm like this is how I
feel I feel like in my entire
relationship life has been I'm like the
wrong shape for every single person that
I find oh so that's that's what and so
are you are you a single father Sean I
am yes are you the soul guardian of them
I am not okay I have there there's a
wonderful woman out there uh who is the
mother that's wonderful I'm sorry that
that um
that you've been so rectangular in your
relationships um here's the video you're
talking about we found it I haven't seen
it maybe that will help us understand
yes okay
okay and how about this rectangle that
one also the square goes in there too
okay good up next we've got this thin
rectangle a thin rectangle that's where
that goes that's right it goes in the
square hole that's not right and up next
a cylinder hmm I think that goes in the
circle why is he doing that now we've
also got the semi-circle right here
so this is interesting though because if
you're rectangular because all the
pieces fit in this case but in your case
none of the pieces fit
or all the pieces fit and then but it's
still not the right shape right so uh I
tend to get along with pretty much
everybody
you know so it's it's more about all
pieces but it's not necessarily the
right one yet I see that's that's a
beautiful message I hope you that you
find someone to fill that perfect
rectangular
and like I mean there's got to be a
rectangle out there it's a pretty common
shape
it is you know what I understand this
song is a lot of people have come out
talking about how they're rectangular oh
yeah start a war between rectangles and
circles that's not the point that it's
it's more about just spreading love
see I you don't hate circles
no why would I hate circles I love
circles wow because there's just a lot
of circle disparagement that's I'm glad
he said that because I was like punching
my my family brought over Bagels this
weekend and I just balled it up
and threw them out man I couldn't I
couldn't even look at them yeah
you know somebody's pretending to be a
circle but they're really an octagon
or something
like that yeah so what's the other
aspect of I traveled whatever 5 000
miles to sing do this
well you know a rectangle song so I had
to go to the most famous
rectangle related which is Times Square
okay I see
I didn't even put that together that's
very good
[Music]
what city do you live in how far did you
travel from or where did you travel from
I'm just curious I'm from just north of
Toronto Canada so you came all the way
down you immigrated
yeah about about a thousand kilometers I
could have gone it wasn't I didn't fly
there so it wasn't exactly a thousand
kilometers kind of walked through the
airport and according to my steps
counters about a thousand kilometers
well I was saying I don't know how far
it is to our studio but you can travel
we can do a live set maybe put up a
triangular stage and you can you can
travel or I mean sorry rectangular I'm
sorry whoa whoa whoa whoa crazy dude
is not triangular it's Rick rectangular
I mean that is cool I will point out
that most stages are rectangles as they
are
so there's a lot of good rectangle
things yeah so our
okay so I'm getting some Intel that from
Toronto to New York as the car drives so
that means it's even more than by flying
is about 790 kilometers
Brew but if you if you walk around the
circle go get gas get some milk do some
other things
[Applause]
nailed it yeah that's kind of I mean I
want to give it to you that's 300
kilometers of funeral
I get I get lost a lot how long is the
scenic route right so um the rectangular
rope so are you working on more music
this is your one single right or is
there more
oh no there's tons I release a new piece
of music every month typically on the
14th of every month uh I think 75 songs
might be 80 now on uh Spotify and
YouTube Etc hold on we went to Sean
Evans
music on YouTube Sean sorry Sean Stevens
I know Sean Evans it's or because I'm
thinking of oh the uh I don't know it's
I don't have a hot one yeah I'm sorry
Sean Stevens music
I released I released the song a couple
weeks ago called hate me which is all
about the online hatred that I seem to
be uh attract very easily I think
because I come out as a CEO and
everybody hates landlords and CEOs and
everybody else is that why they're
hating and that's I'm sorry you
you do seem like a genuinely sweet guy
we don't we're not here about hate
thanks unless you're a circle
my point was uh I actually am okay with
the hate man if you people need to hate
me that's okay because if you need to
get it out of your system I got wide
shoulders bring it on nice there you go
I like that attitude
you know what was that you you hate me
oh let's hear your new song uh if that's
okay with you shall I play it okay great
hate me
was this art made in AI
it was not it was made by a Polish
artist
oh apologies it does look really good
that's why I guess I we've been looking
at AI art and it just kind of
it does it does sort of have that AI art
feel but I wanted to make sure that I
brought a real artist to do the work for
doing that and that's good that's he's a
man of the people he's a man of the
people
you know most most CEOs would probably
just pay just you know have an AI do it
all right here it is
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll give you the space To Love Yourself
[Music]
so how do you what's your process of
making the music you you write the
melody and then you you play with other
folks
uh yeah so cars so I'll play the guitar
part write the guitar part take it in
the studio play in front of a group of
band members say here's what I want and
then have a producer work through that
that's nice I'm gonna come back and
forth and say I like this they don't
like it's another Artisan Etc and
usually five or six artists or so nice
again man of the people
you know
hey turn it up let me hear this
down very positive message
[Music]
that is a fire of her and it's like yo
you want to hate me well I'm gonna give
you the space to love yourself because
clearly that's what you need to be doing
right now hater ass
hater ass loser ass
idiot
haters I got haters too I gotta work on
how to address my haters better
you have haters though I mean what do
people say yeah I don't know who could
hate Sean what do they say
have you not read any of the hatred
comments it's it's pretty thick it's
pretty good
more before when I first got done on
Tick Tock maybe six months ago it was
pretty much just astral hatred at all
the time I had to Wade through all of
that to find a single person was there
did that kind of negativity get to or
were you able to kind of just let it you
know wash off you
uh you know I got them at the beginning
because it got to my kids but well after
we sort of had a good laugh at it it was
like this this it's nobody here there
knows me I mean they're making a random
comment about having funny hair funny
teeth that's awesome and I'll laugh at
myself uh you know fun so the truth is
after I got through that initial hatred
is fine now just like bring it on man
dissonance who cares good for you uh
that's good I really like the video you
made with your employees where
everyone's like I'm over it and you were
making it all listen that was good I
like that that's funny
well um oh have you seen this we have um
hold on
we have a a musician in our audience
beast from space very talented guy he
made a remix of rectangular
this was good right you want to hear Let
me play this for you a bit you might
enjoy it
is
[Applause]
[Music]
this happened
you you're on Tick Tock have you seen
that tweet by Howie Mandel where he
showed the massive prolapse
no you didn't do you want to see it
should I see this I mean it's like it's
kind of it's Tick-Tock it's very graphic
it's it's it's important Tick Tock lore
in my opinion
can I unsee it later if I need to
um yeah okay okay let's let's see it
let's go yeah you can unsee it that does
that doesn't work that way oh you can
unsee it I don't have a Men In Black
zapper but you might You're The Tech Guy
you just pull it up on your computer I
guess how do I pull it up wait there you
know what I don't have an easy way to do
it oh that's probably better it's it's
it's for the best you can look it up
later in a while since I showed someone
that yeah I'm not set up
this is true yeah that should be a whole
section Nostalgia for the prolapse a
prolapse is in a sense
oval-ish
tubular it's like a tube yeah it is a
circle
so a prolapse
that's not I mean it's not rectangular
in any sense of that word yeah not not
related not related this is Sean Evans
this is I'm sorry you know the guy from
hot ones he's a circle so I'm not gonna
ever I'm not gonna honor him again
I don't like him
Sean Stevens Forever
um okay well listen I think the song's
great and I think I hope that you keep
making music and you know what I mean
despite what anyone has to say
and you got to make a song called
the haters I'll find out where you live
you got to come out harder on them
and then we think about that one are you
armed okay I'm Canadian we don't arm
ourselves
really I guess it's harder to get a gun
in Canada right
sure is it I think it's just it's hard
it's but it's very possible that's it
and with your and with your wealth and
connections you could definitely get a
weapon
yeah but we we leave our doors open here
and help each other you know get to the
corner store and that's how you're going
to get the haters that's my point
they're not going to see it coming
that's true all right we're not I'm
kidding we're not in favor of hurting
Our Haters we want them to love
themselves
but um what's such a pleasure to connect
with you Sean I'm uh we're we're we
think you're so sweet and uh really
really quite talented
thank you single theater you guys are
amazing I'm gonna send you you know what
I you know make sure that you guys are
the first people to see my music video
uh this week I'm gonna get it out
somehow and get it over to you guys and
if you like it I would be really
appreciative
should I promise do it we'll watch it
yeah absolutely
I love it yeah but if you ever want if
you're in ever in LA and want to get
rectangular with a live show we're here
we can set you up I'm in yeah
the only difference is that I'm gonna
need you to be more
just because you know I don't want to
misrepresent anything we're gonna have
to be more
honest about the distance traveled
yeah like really like explicit do I have
to like measure it as I go we're gonna
have to get a more precise measurement
yeah
I'm okay with that that's okay I feel
like that's just the only compromise I
have other than that you're I would love
to see you out here to do a live
performance that'd be fun
amazing I love that
um thank you for for calling in I was
very very pleasant nice to connect with
you
guys show really appreciate it
very good man are you pro-union or
anti-union
Pro Union connection
well said well said
thank you all right I'm not gonna I'm
not I'm not gonna keep pushing that one
thank you buddy well great connection oh
4 000 kilometers dude that's huge from
LA to Toronto that's way further than
New York
it is I have to write a really good song
for that so I promise you I'll bring you
a good song for that one I'm excited all
right well stay in touch thank you again
appreciate it yeah have a good one out
there
[Applause]
it does seem like a genuine dude out
there man seem like a sweetheart
you know I I got mad respect for people
to follow their passion like that forget
about it
you know unless your passion is raping
people which is what Russell Brands was
then I don't respect that that's bad I
just got to update that he is formally
being investigated
[Music]
it seems like the crimes happen in L.A
UK
okay well we know how those how those
goes from Andrew Tay and he's fine let
him go all right
dude Russell Russell's about to move to
Romania
start a webcam business
yeah but anyway we love Russ uh we love
uh Sean Stevens music
what a guy huh
it's a cultural movement I mean
that's what it is squaring up squaring
off so where where were we
real quick uh also on the subreddit
someone pointed out that they noticed a
watermark on one of the tattoo mock-ups
outside right now no shot
no way very closely
dude hold on there's a are you gonna
tattoo the watermark on me too
let's get that in there
hold on hold on I gotta see this to
believe this
oh there is a Watermark
here where they have circled I could see
it but also if you look to the very
right of the circle here yeah you can
see it more there I feel like what
he would have tattooed that on me I feel
like
I feel like he would have done it
because it's removed everywhere else and
it kind of just it kind of just fits in
there he would have straight up put
audio jungle on my arm
yeah what uh this uh
this one that cam just sent it's a lot
easier to see what's this okay I like it
Picasso man how did this all go down
like this man
um
it is a little traumatic I was pretty
excited to do this this week I've been
looking forward to it yeah it was gonna
be fun
hold on I'm reading about the I still
think you should just get the top hat
one
suck it up it it
all right it all right it
let's go I'm sure he'll love to come on
the show now and promote his business
yeah
oh sorry one sec
uh okay
[Music]
I'm just trying to get the classics page
fixed up here okay uh somebody's only
five bucks and said I also did a
rectangular remix uh featuring AI Ethan
it's on my YouTube page so go check it
out all right I'll buy it
oh let me see if I can yeah you can pull
it up from the comments
normally it's not common it's a
thank you
I have a question for the um the
audience
okay
what would you like to ask
now Jamie Lee on Howie's show was
tremendous success
my question to the audience is this
should we keep the momentum going like
I'm I'm fairly confident that I can
reach out to Bobby Lee and maybe some
other people and get and get him a spot
and just keep the momentum going until
I think we could get him on I think we
can get him on uh
Jimmy Kimmel with the momentum we've got
and the writer strikes over I think we
can get him in that main seat
I don't know I don't think so what do
you guys think about getting on Bobby
Lee though and just you know seeing so
once he's on Bobby Lee he's on Howie I
mean he's got an end to any podcast in
the world
not a lot of enthusiasm in this room I'm
sure I mean I think it would be
hilarious someone would be canceled I
fear what would happen that's what I was
gonna say
um that will definitely be the end
the Jimmy Lee Saga do you think Bobby
would destroy him I think so
well not not destroy him but I think
I think Bobby would feed off of his
energy and encourage him to take him on
he would egg him on in a way that would
get him to say something way over the
line that's exactly that would be the
end of of the Jimmy Lee song
but that sounds kind of good yeah I mean
I'm not saying I'm against that I'm just
saying I mean worse than he already has
and he's still family because even that
well he could say something more you
could definitely say something worse
because yeah obviously how he's like a
total sweetheart
especially with like Jimmy Jimmy's whole
thing with
with Asian people
talking to Bobby but they're chemistry
their chemistry would be amazing yeah
it has to happen I think their chemistry
would be amazing
all right well do you want me to throw
should Ethan get Jimmy on Bobby's
podcast yes sir yes no and then also
please consider the fact that it may
ruin his life there's a shot there's a
chance
do you think it will ruin his life but
it might end his career quote unquote
and his comedy career his comedy career
his comedy career uh okay that would be
such an explosive show man
I bet I could get him on your mom's
house too come on but that's also kind
of a I feel like he would
I'm I'm more worried about the tiger
belly crossover Tom and Christina can be
a little bit Yeah they can but it's a
different I don't know it's wild in a
different way Bobby's totally unhinged
yeah he crashed the Gatsby man well the
overwhelming majority is saying yes
you know yeah but like he wants to I'm
giving him all the opportunities he
wants to do it and if he can survive a
Bobby Lee podcast then
100 chance bobby gets him to drop the
n-word no
Timmy doesn't use that kind of language
I know he's old-timey not that old-timey
right
crickets
when I was a was a guy who grew up in
the 50s in New Jersey ever used the
n-word
how do you think
I think
for sure that he's 66. I guess maybe he
grew up in the 60s would be closer later
60s that's what I said that was my guess
yeah yeah
um I don't know about Theo Von I'm not
sure if he's in the he gets pretty yeah
I know
but if we make him get I mean people are
saying it's possible I guess to get him
on Joe Rogan after he hits everyone else
people are saying maybe not I see a lot
of suggestions not tiger belly but bad
Friends the one with yeah do they have
guests I don't well no I don't know to
be honest but a lot of people are
suggesting it so
but they don't have guests they'll have
like co-hosts every now and then yeah I
think I think they could make it happen
the thing is if he goes on Bobby and
then all these guys like his energy
because let's be honest you can make a
really entertaining show with him
like they might actually want him on
let me mess I'm gonna text Bobby
he's probably yeah they have shows
what's your fear that they're gonna
steal them no no I want good things for
Jimmy I'm trying to promote him
no my fear my fear is that
no I don't have a fear there's no fear
no I'm Legit want to I want Jimmy to
succeed because if they want to take
them by all means let them have them no
stop it
Jimmy's ours you're saying they do have
guests love they do yeah here let me
text him well there they go
there you go he's probably still
sleeping so you're degenerate
Bobby
I need a favor
this is a good Instagram post to show
Bobby Lee if he wants to know who we're
talking about yeah there's this guy
that was probably the
that's the first time
what the was this I don't know it
says bring amazing never Caucasian but
just be sure to bring him and then he
tags himself
one of the more shocking posts that he's
put
is there a lore to this photo
I have no clue huh it's AI
generator oh it's an AI one I think so
yeah I thought the same it must have
been it must have been
what's his name well I'm wondering maybe
they hired someone new who has like
weird taste in memes and like well Jimmy
clay not be posting him Jimmy posts
everything himself though yeah they
that's what he's explained several times
to us they sent him and then he posts it
and then he but he doesn't ask me any
questions we've proven that one of the
top comments says first post I genuinely
Believe Jimmy posted
I just wait some I saw a good suggestion
next time all of our trees in here
getting him together with Jimmy come on
Epic he's actually coming in soon right
he doesn't cancel who knows who
knows such a loser that guy dumb
I don't know why I keep scheduling him
and then he keeps canceling it's like
bro and he asked to come on
he goes let me get on get me in on
Wednesday
like all right Tuesday night sorry bro I
gotta do some other it's like okay
what the what's more important than
this show for your career
specifically
you know can we get Oliver Anthony
instead
probably not Superior Oliver I kind of
I'm not really a fan but it's still
better than all his appearance
fee I can't afford that 120 000 right
yeah yeah that's rough
next thing all of our trees are gonna be
asking me for appearance fee
I mean yeah though I mean you should pay
us exactly he's invoiced me like 20
times over the years he just like he
emails me of in giant invoice and just
like I'm not paying that is he for real
when he does that
I think so he invoices us yeah for like
what for like 50 pulling up pulling up
for like 15K
it has personal information I can't show
it oh real quick Jimmy just text me he's
watching yeah can we get him out here
um he said like the Asian pick
uh what's going on with Bobby Lee
don't like the Asian pick
up Jimmy
what's going on with Bobby I'll tell him
we're trying I'm trying to get him on
Bobby's show
does he watch every day yeah I think he
is his uh
whatever the you want to call him
he has eyes and ears yeah he has eyes
everywhere let's see if Ali London wants
to call back in and have him in Jimmy
talk
it's gonna be magic
um I have a play date so Jimmy
I've got the call out to um
now Bobby let's see if he gets back to
me Jim said wow I love you guys wow do
you unlike the Asian post
went viral
did it how many likes it viral I might
pull that up ask them how much it costs
it went viral it has 3 000. it has three
thousand left I mean I guess they all
have three thousand exactly ask them how
much it costs
how much it cost for the AI
all right thank you moving on
I mean most of us put it has the same
amount of likes to like all of us posts
like Ryan Kavanaugh for example yeah
does he think that every one of these is
viral you should bring them Asian never
Caucasian right okay
um let's see here
sneako uh
I guess has been hanging out with
um Bradley Martin
which is really cool
of Bradley to hang out with a guy who's
favorite movie is uh cuties
but this was actually quite good and
shows what a little ass punks Nico
is
so Bradley owns this gym
and they hang out there and snico
he's lights up a cigarette in a man's
gym
that's crazy I'm Bradley uh
responds appropriately and snico just he
melts into this tiny little dude
anyone that has respect for him as like
a quote man
see what a child what a baby he is man
such a this man
just he's so insecure watch this not
kidding though
I'll smash a camera right now no
I'm not playing Bradley don't hang out
with dudes like this man
hey it's out it's out yeah I'm not
kidding go put the out it's ow bro
why is it still burning burn your
hand man put it on your
hand man that doesn't even hurt how do
you do that
it's out
it's out I'm not playing
is that I do light a cigarettes the
other security uh cleaners it's out dude
can I have a cigarette I'm not playing
it's out I'll smash your camera
you don't it's out I'm putting it out
I'm not playing I'm not playing
no I'm really not playing with you I'm
not playing either actually like
actually who lights a cigarette in the
gym what do you want to do especially
your friend like your friend's gym like
what that's crazy right
make your mind so he's he's claiming
it's out because the camera's dipped so
it's just he's just lying yeah he's
lying like obviously lying why are you
still having
something yeah no no but I'm not
good I'm not good with that joke's done
yeah I'm not kidding okay what a
she is
I'm gonna end this I'll smash this
goddamn camera right in front of your
face you don't you do that again I
swear to God bro that's disrespectful
and he Bradley's angry and I don't even
think it's about I don't even think it's
related to the steroids
that's just real anger right there
you know Justified
Street anger
don't with Brad sneako the truth I
said you can smoke weed in here you're
not smoking cigarettes in here one apple
bold I'm not kidding I'll smash your
camera right in front of you I'm
not kidding you said that you're
disrespecting me by smoking in my
gym and I'm not kidding I'm not
kidding at all it's all right there's no
more cigarettes
bro he's gonna go 100
he's gonna go 150 it's out bro yeah it's
so heated because I don't like like
that I'm not playing that's a funny game
but I'm not playing it's out I'm not
kidding don't do that again I'm not
kidding I didn't yeah
I know I I saw it in his eyes bro that's
the same look he gave me when he spared
nah that wasn't the same look that was
that was about to hit you dead with my
face that was the famous that
was not the same look that's the look
again I wasn't the same look you know
it's just I love watching Bros fight
he's growing it out man we're in the gym
we're we're arguing in the gym
sick Everyone's Watching that's not
respecting me at all and the too
was respectful
you act like I wanted to do that you
thought I wanted to do that you did want
to do it you bro I told you three times
he's bitching about I guess they sparred
and Bradley knocked him out yeah he
them up we should watch that uh
we were debating it before the show I
think it might get us yellow too violent
I mean it's like full contact like being
the show I thought they were wearing
gloves well he's wearing gloves but he's
hit them hard enough to lay them out
flat on the floor so I just punching
looks so funny because he's so big yeah
he looks like
a toy like a toy fighting machine
like an action figure yeah
I didn't make you do it bro you called
me on a phone get this on camera
you call me on the phone in the
in the SUV with this guy and I
said we shouldn't do it multiple times
you came here I said we should do it
multiple times bro he's nah he's not
gonna I'm not then I was not mad now I'm
mad and you know it's different now and
I know you know it's different he's such
a
I don't give a I told you don't
smoke in my
it's not a joke there's no more smoke
not a joke there's no smoke don't
disrespect me in my house like
that I mean that for real there's no
smoke just they can't apologize it's so
broken there's no smoke he's so brought
up you can't just be like sorry bro I
won't do it again yeah that that would
that would sacrifice too much
masculinity he would feel like a
if he apologized to his friend
this is this is the bro that we're
missing out on guys y'all could be
participating in this Zoo culture but
y'all want to sit here in front of
computers like babies
you'll catch me and not knocking each
other out
I'm Gonna Knock love out right now
you do it bro
ice cream don't eat ice cream ice cream
bro I told you I put that on the
carpet I I eat it what the
bro
put that ice cream out cam did I see you
eating earlier you're not allowed to
eat the are you gonna do
about it Dan I'm Gonna Knock You the
out
you step over here
my show bro you got no smoke shut the
up
what you want to stand up sit down sit
down I just get pissed off that Dan is
eating like these chips here yo shut the
up y'all eat whatever I want down
dude yo shut the up I'm gonna eat
some more ice cream bro
hey Ethan watch your back later
I do
yo what the what did I tell you
about threatening people in My Gym Bro
I tried to I tried to save Bradley man
because there is a good side to Bradley
although he's it's obviously like
it's it's buried quite deep yeah he
doesn't have a problem associating with
the worst people in the world and
actually no not even stop being friends
with I try to save him you know I mean
I said Bradley there's another there's
other ways to live
he's like in the Mormon Church there are
other ways to live dude
you can escape this you don't have to
live this way
bro I just want to eat some bread I you
can eat bread come hang out with us we
can eat bread together
starts crying I just want to eat bread
man and eat a french fry and it's like
it's so hard we can do that man
it's okay and you won't you won't even
really gain weight you just have to eat
at moderation
hey you can still shout and play Make
Believe look at us that was a lot of fun
yeah let's yell at each other more yeah
shut the up you shut the up
what are you looking at me
just the first person that caught my ass
say yeah Zach shut up dude enough
stop
don't do that my Gym Bro oh he's looking
tough what you pissed now you're pissed
what are you gonna do about it what are
you gonna do about it bro the Jewish
holiday stop this take that outside
oh God he's right stop being 100
Ashkenazi in my office where I told you
not to do that take that outside
this bro
Ian you want to yell at somebody you
want to go right now dude you really
want to go right now me no hey you wanna
go right now no Ian you can't button
yourself it's my button
you can't button yourself in
I think it's the idea he has he
understands he's a very private uh
citizen he knows he's a private person
yeah
Sam are you here
do you want to yell at somebody
do you think Ian once steal somebody and
he's just being told back
what's going on here Sam
I'm sorry what was the question I was
trying to get Ian to participate in our
Alpha ceremony and he won't he won't do
it won't even talk
he's just hitting the button
I don't know do you want to see my my
ash rat Crocs I do yeah oh yeah I'm so
excited she just saved you Ian put him
up put him up your girl's got your back
in
breaking news
breaking news Shrek Crocs I have my
pair too
wait where did she go oh she got to go
grab she's going he's just a trek
Shrek Shrek Crocs oh my God therefore
sure is a Shrek dildo out there I'm
sure of it though oh the green screen
you can't see it looks great oh it was
amazing
[Applause]
Shrek how do you like that how you guys
we'll do them together because I want
mine
that's funny yeah wait oh okay we're
gonna we're gonna team up
where does it how much were those it's
like a hundred bucks
60. that's not bad
you know you got a license the Shrek IP
I mean that's those are prices on prices
on prices man
Angel Investing Jimmy to get on bad
friends podcasts
well let me just get Jim uh Bobby Lee to
respond to my text first
thank you for the donation
should we offer that donation to Bobby
Bobby I'll pay 50 dollars
I have my boy Jimmy on
I think that's fair I'm not sure if
that's enough to move him no
let's see what else we got
yeah so shout out to snico I guess he
just lost so much to testosterone being
bitched out by Brad the bull
he can't be breathable we already have a
brad the bull in our uh he's that he he
treating shaniko like Ryan's wife right
now right I guess there is the sneako
cooked connection there there is
interesting
huh
huh I'm not sure what that means but
there's some parallels here I've noticed
more people not people like just dumb
annoying kids and internet people
talking about snico like he's
someone to look up to or something
have you noticed that like he got kicked
off
YouTube's pretty popular
Yeah by like those racist kids that's
discriminatory kids
I still don't understand why I can't
smoke inside the gym
anyway should we call Bradley
I'll be like bro why are you hanging out
with him man you're better than this
that's Bradley if you want he has to
find me on this podcast Bradley needs to
find his own way to the light you know
we can't you can show him the path but
you can't walk
that's true we tried we did I tried my
best with Bradley I really did you fold
um okay so shout outs Nico being cucked
the second time in a couple years time
frame
then in a b what is this we have some in
harmony giggling
see
oh shout out Colleen forgot about her
ugh
um
[Music]
yeah we did you guys even pitched up
yeah that was nice more time probably
just reference
um
[Laughter]
well done the was so funny Zach
well done boys
oh speaking of Sigma brain uh somebody
on the subreddit actually
is a fan of Sigma brain and really put
it to good use here shout out to this
um this fan and supporter Patron
Evan
oh six four
glad you got a signal brand and he's
enjoying it
White Lightning
to stick my brain dude I was thinking
about that NyQuil chicken Meme and I was
looking at my bottle of Sigma grain and
all I could think about was making Sigma
brain chicken so we're just gonna make
it a small little chicken tenderloin add
some oil here
and then we're going to add it to the
only we're gonna add the only seasoning
we have and that is
I'm just screw taking like two scoops of
Sigma grains come on bro I think that
let me show this around do you like it
here's the thing
let's get this on the grill my brain is
so powerful I think it's gonna be good
now look at this chicken on the grill
look at that color a couple of minutes
you know that look at that nice cook a
nice crispy chicken flavor
only the best of the sigma brain chicken
out there yeah close the top four nice
little bite-sized pieces of Sigma brain
chicken right here some Sigma brand you
know look at that beautiful color
gorgeous wow it really is stunning
oh god
oh he's gonna like it he's gonna like it
he mocks it
okay no
no oh interesting
a lot worse
that'd be a lot worse
[Music]
yes go on okay I'll be honest I thought
I would like dag into the whole like
over exaggeration bit but
I mean I'm not gonna finish the plate
but uh it's not that bad it's edible
wash it down buddy and that's what I
like thank you oh actually we're going
to innovator
yeah exactly all purpose
yeah Sigma brain man he's out there I
keep seeing people saying like
I just wish they didn't make it spicy
and I have to emphasize so much it's it
it's not spicy it's just a little zest
on your tongue oh you're saying for
people that haven't tried it I don't
like spicy and they're scared to try it
yeah it's
it's not spicy yeah I go as far as to
just flat out say it's not spicy it's
just has it's just a little sensation
the hint of something hot similar to the
kick of Ginger I would describe it you
know what I mean like when you no it's
not even Ginger can kick your ass dude
that's like well no if it's if it's like
just a little teeny tiny like special
it's like a little fairy dust on your
tongue it's a little fairness
Tinkerbell's in your mouth sprinkling
fairy dust on you she tastes just like
the margarita
uh so shout out to him thank you to all
the sigma brain Nations out there shout
out Adam McIntyre
was reacting to a clip of ours
and
I will say that he wisely skipped past
this section that he thought I might be
saying something offensive
because that's you know I'm a little
crazy like that dude he's edgy I'm crazy
next so we need a button so look at this
oh look you never know what's gonna
happen
[Music]
scared of the jokes that Ethan's making
so I'm gonna skip ahead fair enough fair
enough
socialist it's not the same as someone
saying let's kill all gay people that's
not the same
that was pretty that was pretty funny
oh
out of everything in a four-hour pocket
we're gonna skip ahead I don't think he
land on that I don't think he could have
skipped to a worse possible and like
totally out of context still
isolated just perfect yeah wow thank you
by the way for context it was um I was
saying
uh we were talking about the sneako clip
right when the little kid was like kill
gay people right right right right right
right and I was I was saying no don't do
that right
which is so good
[Applause]
so good Ally Champion
you're a hero in the trenches every day
thank you
um dude I've been getting so many crazy
chiropractor videos are these people I
think they're doing crimes on on screen
I think there might be
I don't know you guys know medical uh
malpractice right they're not even
doctors though
yeah
to do medical malpractice I guess that's
just malpractice he's just a dude
in beating people up
they must be sadists look at this poor
guy he's got an extreme okay oh God
damn it nope never mind moving on
uh one more time here thanks so much
this guy has an extreme case
of scoliosis
and who better to you know it's funny
you go to the doctor like dude you need
like major surgery to fix this you need
to do all this really crazy and he's
like and then this chiropractor is like
nah dude I'm just gonna punch you in the
back don't listen to them
I'm gonna hit you in the back with a
mallet you'll be fine
I think this is a crime
[Music]
yeah
I can tell that hit was really
scientific
I'm glad he's wearing gloves to protect
his his uh
his uh Knuckles
[Music]
he's a sadist
look at that shape
that's your queen oh why oh
[Music]
dude please don't go to chiropractors I
can't emphasize enough and I know this
is in Russia and this is pretty extreme
but the ones here are not that different
man no they're not they just making
up dude those actions you cannot
adjusting is not a real thing
this this guy's telling him I'm just
gonna twist your spine that's what he's
doing by punching him in there he's
bringing out the Mallet dude break
look at this he's gonna twist the spine
it's insane
no no no
oh
yeah he's he got a really good deal on
that treatment so
no problem there's another one this one
this next one's even crazier
um
the comment he left her on one hit point
is so funny and true
look at this man this poor lady
I understand the impulse where it's like
you've tried everything you're in a ton
of pain nothing works
but these got this guy's gonna kill you
he
you know
yeah this one got checked the claims out
because it said no impact it's still
there but it doesn't say no impact uh
let me double check hold on
sucks because I love this one man
this one's really good
uh
it still says no impact yeah okay so
let's go for it it
that means they claimed it
but they didn't like
try to take the money or block it or do
any of that track I don't know so
here is um
chiropractor and this this guy she
they're speaking English here so this is
someone you could find down on Ventura
Boulevard
[Music]
that's been cooking up for lots and lots
of years yeah I know this guy's in New
Jersey
oh
[Music]
yeah I remember seeing 18 fractures and
24 vertebrae in this mine
he just did
on her back
that's a doctor right there saying
bada boom in a bam
I would actually love a real doctor to
um react to this
uh
who specialize in this up up and
down up and down up and down this man is
ow oh yes I am oh yeah good movement
there huh yeah
someone said she's licking their hair
trying to get more oxygen relax that
head for me
oh my God she has like no control
maybe maybe the goal is in a sense if he
does paralyze her maybe that will I mean
maybe that's good well I don't want to
feel my pain oh yeah so he says I got
you I got you fam I'm gonna dislocate
your head
wow
yeah she looks super relieved
power's on hold on oh my God my middle
of my bags too did all healing takes
time that this is an Amazon Prime right
it takes time this is an Amazon Prime
he's he's literally
um
do hitting a railroad spike into her
neck
lace that this is an Amazon Prime it
doesn't stop dude she's like oh my my
back and then he just whips out the Jack
camera
yeah they show no mercies these people
are maniacs
this has to stop this Chiropractic
uh it's Madness people we need to talk
about this
these people are quacks they're hurting
people look at this again this is your
grandma being manhandled by some Jersey
bada bing bada boom guy who's dressed up
play doctor
it's not a doctor
literally in two seconds Grandma's gonna
be uh coming in the form of a tattoo
with a bow tie
I know you know what happened her her
grandson was like I'm trying to get that
inheritance so speed it up for real
right look at this oh
has a massive scoliosis that's been
cooking up for why don't you just do
like a hit why don't you just do like a
maker
honor is that what it that is yeah I
think so
you said the scoliosis has been cooking
for a lot of years he said that that's
not a doctor that's not what you say
about scoliosis it's not cook it doesn't
cook bada bing bada boom
has a massive scoliosis if you watch it
enough it gets funny yeah no I mean I
can't help her
and it's just funny like you're right
I'm a doctor I'm a cooking
up for lots and lots of this poor woman
last time I looked at that x-ray I
remember seeing 18 fractures out of 24
vertebrae in this line let's listen
let's make let's go from let's make them
all 24 girl we're here for you
oh yeah
[Music]
this is insane and they filmed this
they're like this is good come to my
practice hell no man so but this
is the frame that killed me where her
tongue is like spazzing out here did
this ladies friends and family see this
video because I wonder if they were
worried
were they like oh my God you can't go
here
that woman is basically 75 dead
relax that head for me oh there it is
charging up
you don't do that man you do not this is
elder abuse this this is what they do in
the nursery home when you're not
watching
dude this is crazy
look at this
wow
wow Flawless victory
power's on hold on
my middle of my bags
that this is an Amazon Prime right
fatality
I told you he's putting railroad spikes
internet talking about the same Amazon
he's like yo this lady's still alive let
me pull out let me pull out the BFG
9000.
did all Healy takes time right
she took her out I'm so so God damn
tired of these chiropractors they're all
such phony baloneys
oh God that was funny
shout out though hope she's doing well
wherever she is yeah she feels better
if she's lucky he'll he'll uh
paralyzer like grandson's probably happy
inheritance
um so shut up we love our chiropractors
don't we folks
um I wish it legit I wonder if like
genuinely if PMP can take that case
that's elder abuse
they have a responsibility to take care
of that poor woman and they're putting
they're jackhammering her neck
foreign
oh you know who this reminds me of that
we never talked about
the the dentist the dentist who's more
up oh yeah let's go it actually
looks like him too
Kenny okay this is fun I've been wanting
to do this y'all
Dr Kenny smile
this guy was discovered on tick tock
uh and he's the real deal this is in a
sketch these aren't jokes this is a real
dentist with real patients and boy this
dude is sick one up Dennis he is
that's crazy
oh yeah and he he got called out by
um this went viral when
what's her name called him out
it was an old singer
oh mama taught was the one that like
mama taught no it was like
hold on
don't you know what I'm talking there's
like like
I don't know what you're talking look it
up there's an old singer not super old
she's probably like 40 45 50.
like Jewel or some maybe it's jewel
is that that's his name you're right
Jewel it's Jewel yeah jewel I remember
Jewel here show me that all right no
rule Jewel yeah I got it what thank you
he'll give you a little taste of what's
to come here
filming is patient this is real
well looky what the cow dog
talking about your outfit oh yeah I
don't know what this is but it's a first
so my scent to me I said where's I'm
wearing it
are you serious
you could actually match your jacket
brown and white
okay all right go ahead and put those
babies in
broke but
ah
you ever like kissed a guy in those yeah
my boyfriend every day you kiss your
boyfriend with those in that was a man
for life that he is yeah you're gonna
get for the first time for sure
oh dude that is so vile
what he's filming this man he just said
you're gonna get for the first
time in a while
dude are you for real right now Jimmy
Lee wouldn't even go that damn far yeah
Jimmy Lee has borders this man dude
dentists are crazy
there's a dentist there is something
there is
something it there there truly is there
could that be
I don't know you know dentists I don't
know if this is true I've heard it we
can fact check it have the highest
uh suicide attempt rate of any
profession
suicide rate they just they're trying to
off themselves all the time I I've heard
this before I'm fine
hey look at the numbers off themselves
like it's been
so hold on it sounds like it might be an
urban legend okay it's
the notion that dentists have the
highest rate of suicide among
professions has persisted for in the
general population for nearly a century
but is there any truth to this let me
read this article real quick
I mean I never understood a dentist they
get so they get paid fat I mean they
just work in the mouth seems like other
doctors have a harder job Chad gbt says
no
there is no consistent statistical
evidence available to approve the
dentist or suicide prone so there you go
in fact most reliable data suggests the
opposite they're living they love it
they love life maybe they're just too
comfortable that's what's happening
um
yeah I guess the joke was that everyone
hates the dentist so everyone's whatever
okay dentists are great they're doing
well we love that this guy's patience on
the other hand
damn those are right out of a Halloween
catalog twenty dollars
take them out
[Music]
imagine your dentist look in your mouth
and be like
dude yo you look like a Halloween
no I just like you like this though
[Music]
yeah but you know what I'm saying what
are the chance almost zero yeah I did a
spicy joke about the dentist
would you think the joke was offensive
or was defamatory the latter oh
oh I can I can hedge my statement better
no I think it was offensive I'm not I
was afraid that was your your opinion
are you anti-dentite I'm anti-deny Kenny
Smiles that's for sure me as well no I
like dentists I like dentists I go there
you know they clean my teeth I go there
they give me they give me really nice
toothbrushes that are really soft that
you can't find on the open market you
notice that they have nothing but yeah I
got that good good I got that good black
market toothbrushes wait let you pick a
toy yeah they do my boys love the
dentist they get stickers me too the
slinkies
mm-hmm
and they're like bullied they have
highlights magazines in their Lobby
so that's the demon uh there's a whole
bunch of content but hold on and take a
look at this it's not related but
I just want to show you guys it again
[Laughter]
all right so anyway
it's crazy
uh here's Jewel calling him out on Tick
Tock all right let's go Jewel what's her
song what's her big song
I was just trying to think of that uh
uh Jewel artist you were meant for me
Jewel uh you remember who will save your
soul who will say oh yes I feel like I
have to like hear it but I know that
song who was can I play like two seconds
of it yeah yeah yeah yeah
and we'll do like this uh
[Music]
you get it
you need a little more ah I think I know
it who will save your song every place
yeah I know that song it's about
it well anyway Jules biggest hits about
to take place on Tick Tock take a listen
y'all I don't get worked up very often
I'm warped up
I'm hot
the Dr Kenny Smiles controversy
this is all a legit this is all my
opinion
but I didn't know anything about it
until I saw Mama top post about it and
apparently this guy Dr Kenny Smiles has
been humiliating women
he has been running these contests
saying he's casting for a show he helps
give free Smiles you're making this
video he is so degrading and so
disgusting and I mean let's be honest
check out some of this stuff
roll it oh we saw this one but yeah we
don't need to watch the whole thing
because it's like five minutes long but
she put this on the radar well she was
thinking she was thinking Mama Todd it
sounds like we gotta go straight to the
source oh show me mama taught Mama
thoughts on the dog okay so this was a
whole situation where Mama Todd who's a
popular Creator like a very loved
wholesome Creator just put out a video
just talking about she had a bad
experience with her dentist and then Dr
Kenny Smiles used this as an opportunity
to be like oh I would love to fix your
teeth come to me and then she's like I'm
fortunate enough to have insurance give
it to someone else who needs it if
that's the case and then so he made a
contest with her and that's where this
all started yo so he like included this
woman in this psychotic
oh here let me pull up a picture of the
video here that girl is one of the
contestant winners
the one that we watched the one the one
that he said no that's what it is yes
sir and she's like I'm doing free work I
gotta here here is um here's here's the
video
[Laughter]
wait wrong link
where's the mama thought video
so mama taught has 12 million followers
on Tick Tock I don't know who she goes
every time
every time dude
all right who's mama taught let's get a
look
chat loves her too seems oh she's a
she's real big Creator so I'm
trying to find well this is her profile
I want to find the collab yeah it's
under a number I can't believe she got
roped into this psychotic thing yeah she
had a
oh my God that's so crazy I know
oh
okay am I losing my I don't see a oh
here it is here it is so he stitched a
video to her
let's see
this time though right here didn't want
to come out
so okay bro okay first of all he's got
the dentist hairline that's what blew my
mind when I saw this too it's the exact
same you could put whose hairline is
that game and it might be hard to tell
that's the mile special though that's
really looking like mile yeah even more
than Jimmy's maybe being around all the
lidocaine
laughs
holy that's the mall yeah so this
guy's gonna this guy's about to proceed
to make fun of a bunch of women how they
look
look at this I mean here's the
here's another picture of him that's
like crazy to see
[Laughter]
[Music]
help me get Mama Todd's attention she
really she broke her partial and she got
some teeth pulled and I just feel like
we can do something for her she does so
much for for truly everyone else and I
just don't think so nice people you know
seems like a nice guy turn that around
on her so I really want you all to help
me get her attention so that we can get
her like the smile of her dreams
um there's no reason why she needs to be
wearing a partial
um I want her to feel proud to to eat
and chew and this guy just you know
Express herself the way she does already
just you know do it comfortably and
confidently so I just need you all help
to to kind of get her to respond to me
because she doesn't follow me back so I
can't exactly message her so oh there's
a little hint of like annoyance with her
that has not followed me back and
I'm trying to hook her up a little
veneer there and I'm not talking about
teeth
um thank you Zach
but like he seems like nice he's saying
nice things you all can help me so it's
the first time I've ever I've ever tried
to to do this so hopefully it works it's
not gonna backfire I promise
and so where does her response then so I
can't find her actual video I've seen it
in t-channel videos but the original
even the tea channels acknowledged that
they can't find the phone she must have
scrubbed you didn't want anything to do
with them yeah you know at this point
she was she was working with him she
said thank you so much for the offer but
I'm fortunate enough to have insurance
let's give it to people who need it if
you're willing and so then they created
the or with him taking lead this contest
to get your teeth fixed okay yeah so
let's take a look at back to Dr Kenny
and
where's well where's that video
the one her video the Dr Kenny whatever
the contest one is oh right here number
eight this time
Dr Kenny responds said he would give
three free smiles to three of Mama's
tots that's really nice
free dentistry that's a mad hook up
right
so one of the winners was Chelsea baby
the girl we just showed
that explains why she's so like
seems to not she's putting up with it
she's put exactly she's putting up with
it she's keeping up with it I'm just
getting I'm getting mine for now for
free for now she's a queen she ends up
speaking about it she doesn't put up
here so um
let's take a look at this
here he is
look at that maoist hairline man
it's crazy so this guy's got a hairline
like he's getting famished a million
people
smile giveaway up to three of Mama's
tots this is a screenshot okay yeah he's
a good guy we love Dr Kenny
and then here is um
Chelsea baby she made a here's her video
submitting asking for help
for the mom and Todd Smiles Dr Kennedy
is doing
um so I'm just gonna dive right into it
I've had bad teeth going on about seven
years now okay so now with the final
context you realize just actually how
crazy this is so now this poor
girl wins and
he's doing it for free so he needs to
get something out of her
I'm talking about your outfit oh yeah I
don't know what this is but it's a first
so when I sent it to me and said wear it
so I'm wearing it are you serious oh my
gosh your teeth actually match your
jacket
brown and white Black's like keemstar so
it's got a heart like keemstar black
okay all right go ahead and put those so
he's a demon
um he posts videos mainly on Tick Tock
or Instagram where his stick is to be
extremely rude and inappropriate with
patience
um
let's take a look
at his Instagram page for example
damn in a tit bucket
can't open the Instagram I closed it
again I have this
um
tick
it's really annoying
where I move the mouse to the corner
and then I keep accidentally pushing the
X that's why I'm always closing the
window up on accident is he gonna talk
to this woman
hold on
let's see
because I was thinking hey what this is
awesome thank you oh you're welcome
[Applause]
this might be yeah here's an example of
one I mean there's tons that's inspiring
man yeah
dude that that's actually
it's got to be a big life change for her
um yeah so give me examples because
here's one
here it is here's our boy that G look at
Kenny
I'm gonna you later what
you said you looked at me with with uh
I'm gonna you eyes not that I'm
gonna you up but I'm gonna yeah one
more time
I'm gonna you later
oh that's good banana it sure is
okay
I wasn't expecting that sorry
[Music]
we gotta get the dentist board eyes on
this man
and there's so much more though yeah so
after this this contest he had with uh
Mama Todd he announced uh actually just
in August that he is gonna put out
another contest for his audience because
he's starting his own show and send in
uh your applications basically sending
why you should get a new smile
so here is a Creator named annaliza who
applied called him out
he responded to her saying I just wanted
to have sex with you no shot look at
this
this is one of the girls at Cinema
application turn on a fan
[Music]
that's what I thought it was a good
example to see the type of patients that
go to him it's like patients who don't
have the money or have no other option
and um my dentist diagnosed me with a
genetic disease called
Philadelphia has
making friends okay
so she's sad desperate for some
expensive dental work I'm assuming these
people who go to him are already
probably very sensitive and insecure
about their smiles and he's just like oh
damn your your teeth look so up
like what the you're there to help
pretty crazy you're there to be uh help
yeah so here's the text she shares
um
she sent him the audition
she says oh my gosh you followed me does
this mean you saw my addition on Tick
Tock and my other Instagrams yes I saw
it he said I'm so happy you saw it sorry
I'm an ugly crier
he said I just wanted to have sex with
you it's fine
what that man wrote that what
oh yeah baby
um another creator
Taylor he asks her for nudes dude
that's so gnarly
yo he goes send me this man said send in
your applications for dental work and
then he's he's like if you want it you
got to send me nudes or sleep with me
now that's the power of tick tock making
making miracles happen
dks casting not Casting Couch be aware
bro stop
stop he can't not be a creep for one
second
and or record himself being a creep if
they're trying to also like
horrible horrible way to speak to the
girl you're trying to Sarah I think
he likes to humiliate them clearly gross
he gets off on it
weirdo bro
um because after I posted this and this
is in response I was met with
this is absolutely disgusting on some so
here I've got the the um clothing
optional so here is the conversation you
have with this other uh applicant
Let's see Trigger warning nasty teeth
this is hers I'm assuming posted on
ticked out with a caption voice over
explaining my story but sending it here
as well for a close-up I didn't
uh include so you sent him a bunch of
videos
close-ups of her teeth he responds thank
you for your video I will pass this
along to Dr Kenny
wishing you all the luck
she says thank you so much
yada yada
what's your address
uh and phone number I'm going to be
deciding who makes the top 50 by making
some trips
in person in person
please send me 10 more pics
of size shape and stuff like that please
show is about a lot of things Beyond
it's cut off but I'm assuming for a
reason so that will help me clothing
optional he said
dude that's nice
how do people how do you dudes still do
this so that is a casting coach he
explicitly said that it wasn't but
you're literally doing the casting couch
thing that's what well do we do casting
cows usually get dental work no
bro that's how the tick tock starts the
girls like maybe it should have been
called casting couch
because of this this is I don't know how
dudes think they get away with this now
because like
to think I'm gonna do this on Tick Tock
people are watching it on Tick Tock and
there's a lot of there's people gen Z
out there they know about what this
is
and he's just straight up like send me
nudes I want to you and of course
you're going to get exposed man also
here's a wife and kids just yeah
sorry to them
yeah
that really sucks for his family
although better get away from him now I
guess than later
man this guy's a piece of work isn't he
levels but I just want to say that if
you're entering into this giveaway just
know that it's about more than just
teeth supposedly and you might want to
go on Reddit
yeah you might want to go on Reddit and
you might
want his name
me okay that's our boy Dr Kenny now
that's one up dentist
Jamie's gotta pass the title
um
where are we yeah uh number 10. number
ten in response to this mama Todd had a
dis disavow him so Mama dot who put her
poor fans poor mama taught me she got
this nice video from this dentist trying
to help people out
and now Gooch advises mom's this is out
of control Mike you just wouldn't
believe okay I have been disappointed
every single day every single day since
I
I don't know like 10 days straight now
probably uh so here's the thing um I
appreciate every single thing that Dr
Kenny has done for a lot of people and I
know that he has changed lives in such a
beautiful way such a beautiful way and I
will always be grateful and thankful for
what he did for the three people that
won the mama taught Smiles uh I will
forever be thankful and so will they and
I am not speaking for they I am speaking
for me but after what I just saw I can
no longer publicly support Dr Kenny at
all actually and I understand that when
your account gets so large other people
might help you at times my girlfriend
Lisa will answer message for me if I
tell her to so I get that we need a
little bit of help I've got a triple
large account so the fact that I only
have one person that helps me we're
already like overloaded so if this was
not you that answered this message in
that manner
you need to address it if it was you you
certainly need to address it and
understand that
you're just too damn grown to be
speaking that way and how unprofessional
and how to gradient to somebody yeah
it's horrible I'm looking for more
videos so is he trying to because I I
noticed in that last message there was
uh one of the messages was I will pass
this along to Dr Kenneth I think he's so
is he trying the bossy thing right
that's that's why because I I assumed
that that was him regardless I don't
think he if he's trying to like
extort women for uh nude pics I doubt
he's letting other people access that
yeah no I very much doubt it too I just
wonder if that's uh what if that's the
defense he's throwing up because it was
my employee or whatever that would be
awesome yeah
yeah and then Chelsea that girl from the
initial video we watched she responded
as well okay let's take a look okay so
this is the girl all right I'm curious
what her thoughts are on this
this is absolutely disgusting on so many
levels I'm truly I lost words I'm truly
beyond the definition of disgusted
and absolutely embarrassed for you Dr
Kenny let me just go ahead and say this
before we get started on this video
I am forever grateful for the smile and
the opportunity I was given and I'll
forever be thankful for that but that
does not excuse your shitty ass behavior
and I think it's about time you get a
dose of reality now I want to understand
I really want to understand why you
think that you
you are up
I really want to know because I like I
said I am disgusted you are a bully
there's no sugar coating it and I'm not
going to show your credit you are a
bully and that is disgusting behavior
that you that you portray on every
platform that you have
let me just say this take away that
money and you are no better than the
next person that does not just because
you have money does not mean you can
talk to people how you talk to people
there are people out here who are
sensitive I am sensitive did I act
sensitive whenever I got my teeth fixed
no because at the end of the day I was
getting a free smile and I wasn't gonna
piss in your corn flakes yeah but that's
what we thought it's really interesting
to hear that because when you watch it
like oh they must be friends they must
know each other
no he was just
That's crazy dude here I want to see
more of his videos here's one of him
um hold on one sec
here he is working on an old lady's
teeth
oh he's he's uh grinding on this old
lady yeah he's grinding on her here it
is
it's funny I wasn't ready that time
every time
[Laughter]
now here's the video
it's just us I think Dan I don't think
anyone else likes it
yeah they just don't get it they don't
get comedy with you and I do y'all need
to you'll need to study comedy
all right here he is uh doing whatever
the this is
no
[Music]
oh you just put her hand this is your
way of drowning it out
she can't you can't sit on an old lady
first of all wow you got any other ones
of him working on people's teeth
uh I'm going through her now like
weirdo bro
um
let's see
yada yada yada oh this is shazinator is
another Creator who is friends with
Ophelia
blah blah
here's a video of uh Kenny grinding on
her picking up an old lady is this
different
uh that's the same old lady but that's a
different the grinding video
dude this is straight Jimmy Lee
right
like filming in the office yeah yeah
except at least Jimmy uses damn actors
not real patience
wasn't it a mix you see all the names on
here these are this is all um
petitions sent to the Dental Board to
have him disbarred
there's nothing wrong with this one is
there
uh a b
if you dump her out of the chair or what
I mean she's she's probably not even
completely there he's just using an old
lady for his content a little prop yeah
a little prop action
man
he's done a lot worse than that
um it turned people are starting to look
into Dr Kenny Moore it turns out that um
he actually has a history of drug fraud
that's yeah why is he so allowed to do
Dentistry then like if you have drug
fraud that's like GG you know here he is
you know I read into this and I was a
little confused by that too I don't know
I guess maybe because he did it he did
it really early into his career
um basically he wrote himself a
prescription and signed his boss's name
because you you can't uh you can't do it
to yourself that's crazy yeah and then
uh and he got away with it for years and
it wasn't until years later when he got
looked into for something else
um which he ended up getting exonerated
on but in the process of investigating
that this old uh instance of him writing
himself a prescription came up and he
got in trouble but what he wrote it for
huh does he say what he wrote it for uh
I it did say that I don't remember I
read it last week I forget what the drug
was um Penny wilstead smile again Dental
Dr Kenny
Texas reports uh dentist arrested for
fraud
oh there it is it was that sleep agent a
sleep agent yeah if you go to the next
uh if you go to the next slide wait
that's concerning is uh the Sleep agents
because I don't think he's using them
well and it was for a friend uh as well
no Hydro codon is a is uh opiate
that's a uh narcotic right yeah
according investigation conducted he
prescribed over 800 Hydrocodone pills
that's a lot between June to a personal
friend he also prescribed 30-day
quantities of the Sleep agent so so
pythm tart trait
a drug often prescribed for weight loss
that's weird well I mean the obviously
fake
um narcotic
uh prescriptions is pretty much why the
law exists
um let's see during an interview on May
2nd he denied over prescribing but did
admit to calling in the hydrocodone
prescription outside regular business
hours for his friend
during a second interview
he was questioned about prescribing this
Hydrochloric what the is this
phenterine hydrochloride to other
friends
what the is that
dude he's on some weird
the the like brand names of these are
probably things that you'd recognize you
know what I mean
thought I knew them all I see people one
one of them that we read was uh Ambien
yeah they give that out like candy
just go see a doctor
sleepy and horny no
it is horny uh here's one another I'm
looking for these ones yeah
busted to bust in I'm reading his
description
straighten the this was a
miracle these are not implants these are
custom
viconian crowns from my patented system
oh God it's giving billion dollar smile
Pat didn't system that allows me to
straighten the most crooked smile in
just a few hours
oh
well the lives are so off right now
horrific vibes
that's my smile and actually be genuine
with it
what do you like about it
um everything why are you asking that
open just a little bit
[Music]
those are called Summer tea
you know what that means some are going
this way and some are going that way
they're everywhere
how's that affected you
um a lot it's more so like I was saying
earlier it's um
if you don't have good teeth you're not
the greatest parent you're not a good
worker you're always going to be looked
down upon
um because it's the first thing you see
it's someone's teeth or someone's smile
all right well I'm excited to get
started perfect you ready to do this as
much as I can be
this is giving such Casting Couch yeah
vibes
crazy man I'm just telling you man when
when his patients go under I don't know
what's happening in those offices
and that's just my opinion but you know
dentists they put people to sleep a lot
and I'm just saying I've heard of stuff
happening when those patients asleep and
also I'm just saying this is Dr Kenny
we're talking about hold it when you say
you've heard of it are you referring to
Seinfeld I am this is just speculation
no but when you've knew I've seen
articles about dentists about people
actually doing that right yeah you're
referring to the dentist Dr Tim Watley I
don't as Tim Watley I say to people
under the influence oh yeah they
suspected him of doing that didn't they
yeah there's a whole episode where Jerry
thinks he's doing speaking of Seinfeld I
think you're thinking Seinfeld no
actually look it up though I'm sure
dentists have been I'm sure it's
happened so and then so you know if
anyone's gonna do it and this is all
speculation it's Dr Kenny
that's all I'm saying
there's no audio or you you muted the
sound oh there's music playing
gotcha
while we wait for the ketchup I mean
here's a here's another suggestion my
God for a tattoo it's crazy that's how I
remember Shredder the shredder does not
look like that just some of these titles
are insane I just sent you one where
it's called Uh Ethiopian teeth can be
fixed too
oh my God come on what the does
that mean
right
what the so here unmute it or is it
still music
that's pretty much it it's just music
okay so summer teeth not bad
here that yeah descriptions are where it
really goes off the off the rails huh
so get this
what the Jenna Jameson what is a
subreddit
this is a place to share the truth of
the ongoing drama that is Jenna Jameson
this is not a snark group or hate group
this is a more an astonishment and
commiseration but that's too long so WTF
what is he doing on this subreddit what
how weird is that I have no idea
okay well it is where it is
is that her is that Jenna Jameson
oh maybe that's why it must be oh yeah
but he has a reputation in this
community
very strange
appreciate you got
you gotta send some pictures of your
boobs
[Laughter]
that's not a joke actually yeah
come on there start asking for free
holy smelly man where's the Ethiopian
one here
is that what you said
another w2f Janet Jamison
are you gonna have to send me that link
maybe separately
oh here thank you
what kind of Ethiopian Teeth did you
bring me to that messed up one Ethiopian
teeth can be fixed too wink face
he goes but for real but for real so
happy to see what's possible
#gorgeous
#dentist
all right okay this guys
what kind of Ethiopian Teeth did you
bring me to that messed up one
no no not really I was like
you know why are you not smiling I'm
like I'm smiling but I never really you
know show my teeth yeah
let me see so we want to close that Gap
yeah
[Music]
I wonder if he's been cleaning up his
his videos since being canceled by this
um probably crimes yeah wait but it
seems
that's crazy to me that he's able to
keep practicing after doing I don't know
how he was able to wriggle his way out
of that one yeah I don't know I looked
into this a little bit too and a lot of
I don't know I saw one post that had
some decent on votes that said because
it's in Texas basically he's able to buy
his way out of it oh I was right it is
because it's Texas yeah I'll tell you
what man out here in Texas some of our
dentists they just like to get a little
wild I understand it's a tough
profession
we like to give him a few tries out here
in in Texas
we got this one boy Dr Kenny
man he prescribed himself like 10 000
fence and all boy he sold them too
but he's a good dentist
he has three distance
God damn
disciplinary actions listed on the
public website for Texas State Board of
dental examiners what is the board doing
is anybody there
that's crazy
let's see
uh here's findings of facts
respondent Kenneth
has a license he has no priors is his
first one
respondent engage in dishonorable
conduct and prescribing of controlled
substances
so this one was busted for that
yeah here's 2019
another one
yada yada
respondent
um
board member
represented the finding effects here we
go
during the time period
respondent failed to meet the minimum
standard of care and the treatment of
patient
specifically respondent failed to
perform periodontal probing and take pre
and post cementation radiographs during
the seeding of crowns and on teeth
numbers see that just sounds like
straight malpractice because I don't
know what that means
during the time of these dates
he failed to keep adequate records of
the treatment of patients
specifically records do not include
vital signs
written review of medical history
finding and charting of clinical and
radiographic oral examination diagnosis
or explanation why these items were not
recorded
um
so that's pretty spicy I guess and and
then this one's just from 2021
did Texas a hell of a place to be a
dentist man
let's see during the time a respondent
fell below the minimum standard of care
again in the treatment of patient one
specifically utilizing a dental dam or
other forms of isolation during the root
canal treatment
identifying and diagnose of noticeable
Decay on the dis I want to ask Jimmy how
common is this because maybe this is
just something that happens when people
complain
can we ask Jimmy about this
Jamie are you watching
the last text he sent me was found the
pic on Instagram the Asian chicks so he
is watching Zach are you here yeah I'll
text him right yeah let's get let's get
Jimmy on the phone we need his actually
his um professional expert opinion on
this you want Jimmy to call in yeah
that'd be great
um it just sounds like he did you know
bad yeah do we need Jimmy to tell
us but don't you want to know like is
this is this common like if you have a
career over 20 years people are going to
complain about you it's only natural or
is this like yeah even this guy's a
degenerate dentist
I mean it kind of explains the pun like
you should have kept reading because
there's it explains what the
consequences of this was border
uh his hereby issued the sanction of a
reprimand which is nothing
he needs to pay a thousand dollars who
cares
it's nothing
you know
but that's three
respondent shall complete a total of 18
hours of continued education uh oh
this dude just got re-educated to
traffic school
went to drug School
for Mal malpractice Dentistry
how to cover Your Tracks better a class
uh people also found videos of his
daughter saying the n-word
um
how old is his daughter
yeah I don't know how what is this video
Abe
I saw a bunch of people spamming about
it in the chat too but uh well before I
watch it what is it uh it's just a video
it's a video of him talking to his
daughter and she's saying the n-word and
she's like don't post this and he's like
oh it's fine he's basically saying it's
all right then
saying it in a song
he makes some jokes about illegals and
is it bleeped oh is it bleep no so like
so I can't watch this if she's dropping
n bombs
bye-bye
huh
so okay that happened and he re oh he's
a fan of Jordan Peterson fantastic you
should be a monster you know because
everyone else you should be no he's not
posting to be the monster clip it's his
favorite quote of all time it says no
can't be your favorite quote that's so
up
virtuous you shouldn't do anyone any
harm
any harm instinct
to win you know you don't want to be too
aggressive you don't want to be too
assertive you want to take a back seat
and all of that it's like no
no
you should be a monster an absolute
monster
you're probably gonna get claimed by
this song in the background I tried oh
no I I checked it I checked it oh really
yeah okay anyway well that's it I've
heard this quote before it's psychotic
it's like a psychotic quote yeah no he's
a crazy person sucks yo I'm gonna be a
death
all time
these people are so vulnerable in this
chair like can be more vulnerable I'm
gonna be a monster
so there that is Dr Kenny
I don't know why I'm plotting
well in the words of uh Joe Biden we're
all rooting for you we're all rooting
for you
so his daughter just dropped slurs and
he's that's that's pretty crazy too I
mean
let's look at some of his Banger videos
let's see
um
let's see here
let's click one random
when enough is enough some Smiles don't
only light in the room they turn on
everything around them
okay so it feels like there's someone
doing the nice ones and then him being
like get alone let me get in there maybe
he does have an assistant
but he's still the one that's he's
clearly still the one that's crazy
between the two like when Jimmy put up
that photo this weekend
a lot of parallels interesting I'm not a
doctor but shouldn't he be wearing
scrubs or something
I was thinking about that too he's just
in Street clothing yeah it's kind of
weird isn't it yeah like the nurses
aren't scrubs
they're like dentists oftentimes aren't
I mean yeah he looks pretty casual
you're right I don't know he has bro
it's pretty cash
someone said why leave the bottom row
yellow I gotta see that
see he's good he removes his talking
that's when he's best
right
hmm
thank you thank you Zach
um okay there's a creep in the Disco
where he says this lady only has 90 days
to live why does she need new teeth
where does he say that I mean it's gonna
send a couple oh hell yeah
there's two links there
no he did not say that there
Anchorage Alaska seriously so you want
some tea you want some
teeth whenever whenever he's talking
it's so crazy me if I was a dentist you
want some tea
what is this world what in the world man
I don't know
you want some teeth a
teeth I hate this player seriously so
you want some tea I can't
respect your elders why you have like 90
days to live
dude that is so unhinged
he goes talking with a retired
talker I don't know about I don't see it
going two ways here buddy
I see you laughing how do we make those
90 days count
Raw
what's your favorite word she doesn't
seem very happy
[Laughter]
well I'm gonna lean you back and try to
see what what I can do for you all right
lean back just a little bit right don't
think it's like the coffee you want some
teeth can we pull that Zach
okay so you want some teeth stop
looking at her I'm not going to save you
these are gonna work good you see wow
yeah I can do I can do I can work
with that I didn't think I was gonna be
able to
I was gonna put some candy corn in your
mouth and call it good
he does kind of have the Jimmy syndrome
where it's like
you can't talk to people that way you
know that right right but he doesn't but
Jimmy at least he understands he can't
talk to his clients like that but
somehow this man Dr Kenny
he's had three he's been written up
three times by the board
he's like ass he's like asking patients
for nudes and this man is still
practicing in Texas he's still posting
videos
maybe not for too much longer I have to
imagine going viral like this uh has
resulted in I tried some complaints so
hard to the board oh this here's his
wife I'm curious how he talks to her
should I click it or no you want some
babies you want some
babies
let's see
what about my wife
and a 10 pound wing and this is working
my abs
and I'm gonna put the on number one oh
what is happening okay so she's weird
too oh yeah come on she just cruise
around like that adds up maybe I should
wear this but Halloween she's covered in
gadgets
um
top comment from four days ago has she
filed for divorce yet
it's awesome
what's it doing
[Music]
anyway she's fine there's no problem
there
having a little fun getting a little
weird while here's another one thank you
love
we can move on after this but
I want to get the full Dr Kenny
experience
there's the sworn affidavit signatures
about the smell of practice
racking them up have sex with you yes
90 year old Barbie meets Dr Kenny this
video is not suitable for anyone who
takes life too serious
oh
that's
that's crazy
yeah I'm like all right because my
bucket list a 90 year old so you
said it your kid and she says you're a
Barbie all right yeah I'm your Ken doll
yes
I'm gonna I'm gonna leave so that you
guys can do like your handicap stuff in
privacy okay
yes
he's like it's awkward and I don't want
to help
[Laughter]
I need to get changed for the ball yeah
he's looking through his on
wow this is like chipping here I have a
picture of the how of how it came out
looks good I mean it's like am I being
punked that was so far this yeah all
right anyways yeah that's enough do you
see about the good work
um
huh did you see that in Discord the
thumbnail I sent
um from his official account oh no he
didn't do that Dr Seva ho it's like he
he just he has like moments of psychosis
where he just
it's like it's all normal dentist
and then Dr Save A Hoe yeah it's crazy
that's his alter ego right there I'm
gonna whip this whole what's that video
like probably not it's wholesome normal
yeah it's wholesome yeah it's completely
Dr Save A Hoe it's super weird
wow
what an interesting guy
shout out Texas man shout out I like we
don't believe in regulations law down
here boy
we believe that we like small government
and we like our dentist to feel our
genitals when we're under
it don't matter I was sleeping anyway
what's the difference gave me a discount
and everything
moving on
thank you everybody thank you Dr Kenny
thank you if you do find more I I
wouldn't I wouldn't hate seeing more um
we haven't seen enough I just feel like
we're missing the really good ones he
probably
he deleted a bunch of them it must be
yeah he probably the craziest smile
again Dental AKA savajo Dental
there he is these websites are wild oh
we can chat with them
watch this amazing video by Inside
Edition nah
[Music]
what do you think it's probably just the
first time you went uh viral or whatever
yeah he's like I can do this yeah all
right take a look at this uh this hoe
here we're gonna save her
well hey Gee lady you got some up
teeth
bone graft man this guy ain't touching
no bone graft on me
you know what that means but I don't
want it I don't want any of it
there he is there he is all right so
moving on thank you
what else we got here
ah
ice Poseidon did this story end up being
interesting or was it like
I think it is interesting
but it turned out he was released like
what happened in the end
he wasn't actually
um arrested for the sexual assault he
was arrested because someone was um what
can we call it
yeah thank you yeah right
so
we could do just uh Pastor Jesse
Duplantis I've been wanting to do
sure
okay that one's pretty good
uh yeah let's do this one you know you
know I love me some
some good pastors out there yeah we
haven't had a new one in a while
especially the ones that know the truth
of God which is that amen
Prosperity is a sign of how much God
loves you oh Jesus oh Jesus and by that
metric Elon Musk and Jeff Bezos and Bill
Gates are truly loved that's right and
that's why you don't have any right to
ask for if their name was in those flags
stop that fear okay God knows God did
goddamn so he's based in New Orleans uh
he's friends with Kenneth Copeland our
favorite is a private jet that costs 54
million
uh he also on the board of Oral Roberts
University that's the king oh
the OG he was granted an honorary
doctorate
Kenneth Copeland's also on the board
here let's check it out
listen to how he talks to his
congregation man
this is this is how Jesus pictured is so
dang here here it is
[Laughter]
it's so funny everything's good wait I
closed the dock she looks good damn it
all right my Tourette's is starting to
affect the show now oh boy yeah I'll
send you the link to the doc I gotta
reopen it anyway oh I got it thank you
oh no this is old doc
all Doc Jimmy he's flaring up right now
was that about me
I think so yeah whenever you're more
stressed and true that's true he's
actually knows a lot for someone who's
not a neurologist
I don't give a
he's trying to compliment you
preach I know man I don't give a
okay you're a deep thinker bro Jesus all
right here let me defend this dude I'm
sorry all right here
I live in the biggest house in the state
of Louisiana isn't that right I have the
biggest house of any preacher in America
that's right I got the biggest house
I only knew 99 of it
I don't mean they love it
[Music]
I have a name to my house
the house of Dreams
you like going with the Wind
my house
oh yeah same
staircase that's Scarlett O'Hara that's
right
oh I paid cash for the home
by the way these are the people who sit
in on these prosperity uh preachers are
just poor salt to the Earth they they
accumulate their wealth five dollars at
a time you know what I mean
and he's it's crazy how he gets them all
excited about his
massive house he paid cash for yo he's
good
you want to know how big it is yeah it's
forty thousand square foot
oh yeah my shock if you look at Kathy
what do you do Jesus we're gonna catch
it again
with 40 000 square foot and a lot of
time if I go out cars start stopping
honking Christmas I walked outside the
front just walked out and a man slammed
his brakes and brother
I said hello and he threw five thousand
dollars over the fence
yeah
that's how it works I said I ain't
telling Kathy nothing
man when you're a good when you're good
like can people just throw money
I guess people believe that I mean
obviously they do
how can you be so gullible I mean geez
Louise I feel bad obviously it comes
from a place of desperation but my
goodness
he's just spitting in their face
there's more of him he's he's like the
ultimate flexor we got to give him that
title
you know
we get mad when I do that this is a
Snoopy
a Snoopy and that's an Omega this here
was the Apollo 13.
do you ever talk about God or
you just Flex on your people
expensive watch uh 007 where Omega okay
okay
that's right
this man haven't said a single word
about God
he flew his jet to the Kentucky Derby
awesome
take a look that plane was worth every
nickel and dime
and when people see it
they freak out man they go look at this
plane
I flew it to the Kentucky Derby you
ought to see people going
look at that plant
I wanted to see them horses run
at the I did they said you land on the
feel that the Kentucky Derby like what
are you talking about people at the
airport were like whoa yeah well look at
that plane that's right never seen one
of those before people were throwing
money just throwing
I walked past coach they were getting
off at a different plane they started
emptying their pockets boy throwing
their change at me I didn't bother to
pick it up because I ain't waste no time
for change but you know what I mean one
woman she saw the plane knocked her on
her ass she was just like I'll tell you
what boy this is a plane she ain't never
seen no plane like that but and in which
she fell dead I swear to you now a
hundred dollar bill came right out of
her pocket straight towards me 100 I
picked up she looks Frozen in Time
Forever yeah this is a video though this
is actually not a still
yeah she you're right she's in motion
too much
he's sad man
that's an athlete's bought in
thoroughbreds I closer and horses are
first buddy now did you get in front of
the hole they don't care if the horse
stomping you just get out the way human
because these horses are worth millions
and millions millions of dollars and I
was at the very top level I was talking
to the president's wife of Churchill
Downs and I didn't even know it
wow nobody cares
I was talking to church his wife and she
opened up her damn purse and gave me a
thousand dollars
when she saluted Me and Everyone clapped
I can't spend it fast enough I'll tell
you what
uh brags about his Rolex talk cost more
than his second house Vibes cool uh yeah
I'm hesitant to say I don't want to say
I'm gonna get all kind of crazy other
people fight you don't have jewelry cost
more in your house
[Applause]
[Music]
listen to me I'm I'm telling you my
first house cost 14 700 I'm giving you a
chance to write to check out fourteen
Thousand Seven my second house called 81
900 and this watch costs more than that
let's get him what do you think
Zach
it's over the top it's too much you
think it's too gaudy would you wear it
if I bought it for you probably not no
really straight up not wear a hundred
thousand dollar watch it doesn't matter
the price that's not it's not about the
price not the point okay well it's two
it's too um
it's too flashy okay
ow I mean I agree so I'm just I'm a
little surprised to hear you say that
but yeah you know what he's he's like yo
I'm wearing a hundred thousand dollar
watch let's get him you don't want to do
gosperity preaching catch him in the in
the parking yeah I'm about to
come around like bodyguards at all times
you know what I mean stop watch
xqc loves that one
cool and house call 81 000. Nick Cage
where is that one Nick Cage yeah hmm
very cool
the watch costs more than that still
wasn't he like super in debt he hung on
to the Rolex it is no he's still got it
I I mean I thought he was like a hundred
million dollars in debt and it was
something crazy each yeah he had
something he like got hit with like tax
evasion or something no he and also like
the most insane spending you can
possibly imagine he had like 10 houses
that were unoccupied with full staff and
the craziest thing you can imagine
that explains the watch then Jesus
explains the roles you've been taking
Nick Cage he said six million owed to
the IRS he still owes six million the
IRS Legend dude I don't know if he still
does yeah this article was from June I
know City paid it off good for him I'm
so happy for him
hey I'm so happy for him
I just want to remind you Ethan uh in
our audience but um this preacher we
actually have
known about him for a while without
realizing it because he is the other
preacher from the whole Kenneth Copeland
jet incident I think they co-owned
they're together yeah I think they
co-owned that plane if I remember the
story that's why they're both here
talking about it
and this was the famous video where they
talk about the uh demons and demons in a
tube yeah
man
so yeah this is all part of the same
ecosystem how is it that it's it's this
is legal not only is it not illegal they
don't pay taxes these two demons don't
pay taxes they don't pay taxes you
understand what I'm saying so
they probably paid
no their Church buys everything they
don't pay a dime
these don't pay I see
because because right they own the
church the church buys everything right
okay they don't pay a dime
they probably came in living and living
in the house that's owned by the church
isn't considered compensation the
government
um
they apparently can't
they can't make that judgment call
I think the Scientology
lawsuits really
hampered the government's
great ability to
regulate this stuff too all right
yeah only the best huh
are you gonna write me a necklace let me
tell you what no no
pridefully
sure you know pride is a sin and I'm sin
him and Kenneth got together
damn can you play some demonic music or
something like that dogs apparently oh
here's the last one of these cubes now
oral used fly Airlines right but it even
back there then man it got to the place
where it was agitating his spiritual
people coming up he had become famous
and they wanted him to pray for him and
all that you you can't you you can't
manage praying for no one ain't playing
this dope-filled world right and get in
an air get in a long tube with a bunch
of demons right that's exactly and it's
deadly and he works on your heart it
really does so anyway
that's so crazy I mean a bunch of poor
people are watching this and sending
them money
with a bunch of demons I just I I don't
understand this world we live in
sometimes can't lie to you and say see
that them preachers spending all that
money just just fat cats riding around
knowing up oh we're not I thought we
were oh this watch college more than
your house
what does that sound you keep playing
it's him somebody named house
okay wait I got a new tattoo option hold
on tell me what you think
oh I like it yeah
yeah
that's nice someone in the audience is
gonna get that now
she could use a top hat we wish she's
doing well wherever she is we wish
[Applause]
um she's sure she's doing great he's
fully recovered that's the point right
her vertebase are back aligned yeah no
she's good Holy Ghost is just gone she's
good her spine as she feels turned in
the right shape
she's spry she's totally vertical now
she's a vertical Walker yeah
Lovely by the way here's a post from the
Mormons they they say um
did I really get them they say the
Mormon Blaze is real
this is something we've been talking
about a bit
check this out
as an ex-warm and hearing Ethan talk
about the Mormons look glazed is so
validating
so anyone who's been Mormon knows that
when people leave the church everyone
uses this phrase the light has left
their eyes that's what I'm talking about
that's so creepy man it is
in order to say that they are no longer
righteous it's a really common way for
people who have left to be shamed by
their family and friends still in the
fold when I posted a public post on
social media about leaving the church I
specifically looked for a picture of
myself that looked like I had light in
my eyes and people wouldn't say that
about me right I had come to think since
being further away from it really is
just people projecting the way they feel
about you leaving onto you saying you've
lost the light in your eyes but after
hearing Ethan talk about the Mormon
glaze made me realize that people who
have left have found authenticity and
are no longer concerned with looking
perfect and being glazed over true so
validating to see this from an outside
perspective and realize that I haven't
lost the light you girl you have never
lost the light in your eyes the light in
your eyes will not
girl listen
the light in your eyes shines so bright
the Mormons fear you because if they
looked in your eyes they would be blind
the lights
your lights your eyes can be seen from
space girl two pillars of holy
matrimony
matrimony I don't know uh I mean if you
want
matrimony yeah we love that
girl you will never ever lose your shine
girl your glaze you've got that J you
got that jelly donut glaze she's got
that matrimony glaze that's a special
you got that
you got that Donuts you know what I'm
saying I like that kind of glaze I like
that glaze that donut you know what they
are they're laminated they're all
laminated you glazed up girl and I mean
that like a donut luck and I love me
some donuts that's a good place sweet
not too sweet
them's laminated type of place you know
what I'm saying
that's creepy though the light has left
their eyes like they're dead
we believe in you girl
[Music]
we trust in you girl we love you
um
that's right
you hear that
[Music]
I tell you what Mom
I left me that Mormon church
I felt it was time for me to go
been enough time being around the phones
and The Fakes out there in that church
and I'll tell you one other thing
brother
y'all don't really know what's going on
in the center of it all
when you get to the third chamber
you get to the fourth chamber
the moment's got Secrets boy like you
ain't never known
[Music]
I've seen things in that fourth chamber
you ain't never dreamed to be real not
in a good way neither I'm Alana
one time one of the ceremonies down in
the fourth circle when little is wrong
he's trying to baptize a girl go for a
record see how long she could stay under
so the baptism was better Hallelujah
and we kept her under there real long
but uh
I guess the devil decided to take her
that day because God won't eat that room
it's the blood of God and when we deal
with their body we decided you know if
it's God's will then so be it but son
but how do you get rid of a body as a
Mormon
where do you put the body you're in the
fourth chamber you carry it out no
there was only one way to get rid of the
body make sure no evidence
there's about eight of us there and I'll
tell you right now I tell you under
God's eyes with light in them and all
we ate that poor girl
we ain't
that was the only way and under God's
will we did it and we got out
and I'll tell you I felt some kind of
Rush eating that there girl you could
feel God's present as I
ate her thigh like a chicken wing
[Music]
the bones weren't easy to put down bar
we had to ground them up into a powder
sip it in our teeth
we got it done I'll tell you
um
I sometimes still think about that girl
her head about six inches under the
water her eyes wide open screaming
she said help I said girl only God can
help you
[Music]
that's not a real book is it oh no his
is monk of course it is no this is 100
real think like now on Amazon maybe you
should think like a monk Jay Shetty and
go to go put on an orange robe
and go get the out of here go
protect beer Monk
leave me alone man I want to win
podcasts
thank you
I'll tell you what though man
oh they wait
there's a new there's a new act in town
dude that chiropractor did her so good
she's a God she's super successful uh
prosperity
yo this table's kind of psycho like just
a bowl of like fake fruits
two psycho looking mugs
those are psychotic so it's so sparse
well what is the wood block under it
that is interesting does it keep it warm
is it one of those like wait it is
plugged in yeah I think it is these
need their coffee worm
like that like that's that important
that sounds nice we should get those it
is should we get them look at them
that'd be awesome I've never used one
you know what though we have power
distribution uh limits as it is and
plugging in a bunch of hot plates it's
probably talking like a poor boy
ain't no ain't God gonna favor you with
that kind of thinking bro
you see the latest thing that loves us
see
um
what the AI one yeah for top hats is
this her oh no
she's not doing well
I know
he's not doing well at all
but this must have been unrelated to the
chiropractor yeah yeah of course you
should probably just totally unrelated
it's a shame I heard she walked out of
there straight as a whistle man look at
that straight clean
and she she would drove out of the
parking lot got T-boned by oh no look
around man bad luck that's terrible I've
fallen and I can't get up
these are scary
dude what the Love's going crazy
with you I'm sending these what so it's
a tattoo of a tuxedo it's like half dog
is that Shredder this I just combined it
with like did you give it my dog's photo
no I just combined it with the dog takes
prompt and added her picture Okay this
episode's getting weird
he's at the relay
I feel like we got to go back and watch
that video before we leave
it's uh it's power it's become a
powerful agent oh my goodness let's go
back up can I send him Discord thank you
all right here it is one more time for
the good guys
Steve just donated ten dollars and said
is that woman the new Mobility Mary yeah
kind of
rest in peace to the queen nobody could
ever replace Mobility Mary I heard what
happened she she actually saw a
chiropractor and that was oh no I never
thought of her chiropractors said they
could uh get her out of the mobility
chair it's all got tattoos of Mobility
Mary instead yeah I don't know it turns
out he was right just not in the way she
thought
here is uh one more time for the good
Folks at home
has a massive
employees
for lots and lots of years
last time I looked at that x-ray I
remember seeing 18 fractures at a 24
vertebrae in this world
they were all old fractures up up and
down up and down up and down like I was
karate chopping her back yeah
[Music]
good movement there huh
yes girl we love it girl yeah
you deserve to feel better yes self-care
day the way her tongue does that
I think that that's got to be a sign of
some kind of nerve damage no the tongue
means that it like feels so relaxed it's
just whipping that's how you know it's
working yeah when the chiropractor hit
different in your tongue whip
just the right spot correct so right she
couldn't pull herself
my favorite one this one just straight
up he's trying to kill her like I don't
even know how else to explain that
is way too much also I didn't hear bone
crack oh my I heard bones integrating is
that like I didn't like listen to that
sound yeah that ain't that ain't a crap
that's that's
just her skeleton yeah well at this
point her bones are paper thin they're
powder now yeah damn dude
oh my God I can't dust wow wow man
[Music]
that all Healy takes time
right finishing her off hey who is this
guy I want to check out his Tick Tock
Devo oh no this is a parody one but yeah
we gotta find out who is he
hold on
let's find the original and see if we
can if they didn't trace it back back
I'll try so ninja reminds me of my
grandma's sad face
you have you have to be a sadist to like
be willing to do this to this this one
is so fragile yeah she's like you you
know when you get a back pain and I mean
just the slightest jerk can just be
devastating I mean this woman it must be
an unimaginable pain like you can't even
dream of what she's going through right
now hahaha
those are real those are her um
vertebrates popping out
you hear that that's a good sound
bada bang
I found the doctor I always find the
video Dr Zev
would you say the doctor's dead no no Dr
Zev is the name of the guy said from
Pulp Fiction that makes sense that's
dead Zev
did you send in the wolf nice one oh
hell no he has a video of DJ Khaled
oh yeah send me that link
wait it has like the least views on his
channel oh no we get Kelly getting
adjusted we can watch coward get cracked
no I have two years cracks yeah there's
even that many views so this is Doctor
Dr Zev this should be this man should be
in prison but we're gonna watch his Tick
Tock instead
underneath right here you're gonna feel
me motion you okay let me relax huh let
me be relaxed well I definitely don't
want you to be tight
yeah but I guess you don't even you're
overthinking it let me do all the work
don't worry you're not gonna be relaxed
this one's got to be boring the reason
why I get this I found a part two with
the lady it's his granny update oh my
God oh my God he called her no pain
Lorraine
no pain Lorraine because she's paralyzed
what do you think about this spine and
brain were severed it's not as good
it's good but not as good
so she went back to him huh
she survived long enough for another
visit
oh yep you okay right there
she's alive you well you healthy you
happy yeah it doesn't look like it
hold the phone man hold the phone this
man's like Okay show them you're okay
and she just doesn't say anything he
just looks into the camera she's like
hey I didn't hurt you right you go ahead
and tell him and she looks scared her
eyes are like
the original says the top comment with
32k likes is bro you're killing her
that's not even a joke that's just a
statement of fact he's like look she's
fine you remember her she's alive you
will you healthy you happy yeah yep no
pain Lorraine she can't even talk
straight man
she was like yeah what cut they think my
adjustment killed you yeah isn't that
crazy yeah this is some people are
watching the video and saying I was
trying to correct the scoliosis or fix
that and at this point she's like what
we're doing now dude he's this now this
is just this woman
she can't talk the poor things
he's trying to mount the defense with
this woman he stroked her out that's it
he karate chopped her back three
times she can't talk
another comment I saw it he bought a
boom bought a bang they're back she used
to recite Shakespeare now she talks like
this this comment says for anyone asking
she's in a better place now without pain
true
that's what I keep saying it's maybe
better if she was paralyzed go for it
bro
why is he Barefoot bro put on some shoes
freak Spanish barefoot what doctor you
ever been to walks around barefoot
that's not sanitary
this man is not a doctor
I have there's no shot
what's his Tick Tock name Dr Zev
man
what's your credentials
remember last time we talked about
chiropractors isn't it like technically
a doctorate that you get but it's like
no it's a phony baloney yeah it's not
like a real no I don't think he can use
the title doctor
that was just all about quality of life
movement bringing inflammation down
getting back into Julian spine and just
keeping herself as happy as possible
when you were getting adjusted why is he
Barefoot does that not troubling anyone
else
oh well it's like you know what
is it I'm not saying it's not troubling
but I mean because it's
you don't a lot of these chiropractors
it's like uh they're like hippie dippy
types you know bro nobody's laying on
the floor
you know maybe he does do that maybe he
walks on their back or something I never
seen it all I've seen is murdering
people in the operating table oh yeah
that was profitable for me it was
profitable profitable yeah she's not
even making sense and he used the
footage though she says it was
profitable for me he's like what do you
think about this
does that work for you that works for me
that's better that's good yo that's
listening to this conversation Nation
down getting Mobility back into the rain
spine and just keeping your ability as
happy as possible when you were getting
adjusted regularly oh yeah that was
profitable for me it was profitable
is that what you said yeah yeah I like
that
just a cadaver with a
Electronics in her mouth that first
video the first one we watched has 71
million views
yeah it's got to be all people horrified
right yeah probably
her body but also it helps adjust the
way that she feels feel a little better
yes God bless you take care God bless
you too and your family oh
all right I believe him yeah she's she's
actually cool I can tell
top comment she came back he came back
to finish her
so you're not in pain Lorraine I got
that gun to her neck you know what do
you mean no pain Lorraine she screams
every time you touch her
he really said she's alive
[Laughter]
Lily this is Lorraine Newman's sister
Maureen we all know what happened to
Lorraine
stick your tongue out if you need help
hahaha
he says you go he goes are you alive and
well she looks around trying to figure
out she's dead or not
oh
these comments are crazy
she said it was profitable because she
was paid to say it didn't hurt her
it was the worst pain I think I have
ever wait yeah that in my life yeah that
totally makes sense yeah I think I think
they're on to something there I don't
think she I don't think she's capable of
like retaking it it was just right so he
just had to roll with it please do me a
favor go to his website and look up his
credentials
okay I found another old lady in the top
comment is POV you came from the other
granny video and now you're here I have
a I have a I have a preference for a
category of
old women being tortured by
chiropractors
it's my favorite genre of videos right
now
gilk granny I like to kill I'm glad I'm
glad you brought the cross because you
better say your prayers right now oh my
God I'm so scared guilt here you know a
little less resistance from the right
trap and tissue less resistance oh my
God
yeah
oh my God
his shirt says adjustments don't lie
I saw I mean we all saw it okay we all
saw it
good
hey guys
it's gonna pop off it looks like a hit
job when they twist their neck and they
come and says come and says she's on two
percent and he's still cracking her like
a glow stick
[Laughter]
s
[Music]
oh wow I'll tell you what
you don't want to cross me again I'm
gonna send your grandmother to the
chiropractor
I like to get even
what's his so what's his story what's
his credentials
love shot sent this little screenshot
from his website
uh let's read the comments POV you came
from the other granny video that's us
I'm scared for the old people granny got
a glimpse of Prince Philip
[Laughter]
oh this guy's awesome this might be
my favorite guy right now no not see now
now
[Music]
but he does yeah he does yes but all
right moving on
all right I made a joke that didn't fly
yeah it was funny though it was funny
[Music]
um oh is this
is this summer or what's her name
Allison Ray
you like that there's another genre of
chiropractors that like
they just have women in like lingerie
yeah
dude there's nothing good going on with
chiropractors man
this this looks like a Kill Shot just
like that yeah a little more get a
little more
whoa
I'm so crazy
[Music]
stop it it's crazy how like they just
figured out that cracking bones
makes people feel that something's
happening and they built a whole
business around cracking bones
which is like such a silly thing there's
cracking bones
paying people to crack your bones
that's it
all right is this guy the doctorate
anyone got a he's been trained and I I
refresh myself on this uh yeah the the
type of degree that a lot of
chiropractors get is technically a
doctorate so they they get to use the
doctor what brain-based chiropractic
care clear infect your brain like a cult
prenatal that's like newborn babies
that's not a real organs there's no shot
that that's a real prenatal Chiropractic
I've seen it's for like for pregnant
women right just never mind is that what
that is
biophysics what are you talking stop
trying to make it sound like something
biophysics
natural detox pediatric chiropractor
there you go
uh postpartum chiropractor ergonomics
what does that even mean that's just a
word
and by the way the way this is laid out
looks like a scam
I've seen these credentials before on
the landing page that popped up on like
some up site
is this Shaq you feel me underneath your
lower neck it's shot bro Shaq is in
every goddamn thing yeah
I don't think he's big enough to adjust
[Music]
movement
gotta lead me from this conversation
oh I don't think he can move man
[Music]
I'm pretty sure like when they say that
you're stretching when you're stretching
correctly it's supposed to feel good I
think the same applies to like
chiropractor chiropractia massage if it
hurts I don't think it's supposed to
hurt
I know what makes you like think that
something's happening or maybe it dulls
the pain that you're feeling but
I think it's supposed to feel good
all right
oh this one looks scared hold on we're
bringing my grandma all right Grandma
and she got warnicky's Aphasia so uh to
last year suffered two strokes and back
to back and ever since then she hasn't
been the same
oh my God this is what he's gonna cure
her Strokes no my man's trying to get
his inheritance
he's like two strokes so close
sometimes we need is one adjustment
[Music]
s
because she subconsciously you can't say
stop she's non-verbal a lot of
contraction I bring her head this way
she brings the head I don't think she
I'm serious there it is she's please
don't who are you what's happening yeah
that does not seem right this is the
kill shot
money shot
like money shots
crazy look at the will
adjudicator in here
hahaha
he's there watching the whole thing yeah
oh that's yeah
she looks scared
she's doing great
yeah dude wait what was that she just
stopped him from recording
camera yeah
she doesn't want to be there that's
actually pretty bad yeah that's horrible
but let's at least cut that out so we
don't feel bad for her
This Woman's just being tortured against
her will still love me
look see they're friends he said you
still love me and she touched him
[Music]
Rosa menaced to the elderly oh no he's
going after another granny
bro why did you include her smacking the
camera yeah
all right I gotta find more old people
getting adjusted this is my genre
a dog adjustment okay there's no way
that this man
for doctors are so specialized I've been
seeing a lot of doctors
like there's a doctor for blood there's
a doctor for autoimmune there's a doctor
for just your dick
there's a doctor for vaginal you know
guy knows there's a doctor for every
time this but this man somehow can
adjust animals babies
adults children that's
impossible bariatric medicine is a whole
field
the elderly this guy's just making
up it's just that good he's gonna why
would you bring your dog man no how do
you even know your dog needs an
adjustment
that is such a good boy by the way a
good dog to not complain about this good
girl
don't don't
there's no way he knows about the dog's
skeletal structure it's such
you're stupid bad dog like what are you
doing man
Chris right I mean this kind of proof
that it's all at least his
supposed credentials
I love it though
this is maybe the best one we've ever
found
here's a granny I think we saw her
here's a child I'm not gonna watch that
damn that's it that's all we get
you guys know any grannies we can send
over there for content
it's a spare grannies
I mean they're they have a good shot
they're not going to make it so just
make sure she's a spare granny
this should be the better on this
website
they look cute wait this lady is kind of
old hold on let's see
[Music]
what was it
with
[Music]
it that's it
oh come on that's the best you can show
what he the man this he's laying his
hands on children that dude look at
that hell no
more
wow
the bones popping out
that one was horrible it just happened
she cried and then it was over all right
guys who's next
let me see this one of him just talking
to the camera
oh God you know what he's got he's got
the
you know when you see like on True Crime
they go to like get all the cleaning
supplies
to clean the crime scene Get rid of the
body that's what he is right now
[Music]
we're gonna tune up some more people and
find some people on the Block oh he's
adjusting homeless future
I brought a table out here to address
people and I got some food as well
you only get the food if you get the
adjustment now back up I got to adjust
you first then you get the sandwich
yeah it's very suspicious that it's like
I'm doing it for free old people who
can't talk back dogs who can't talk yo
no homeless people that if I up you
know what I mean that's so true man
nobody's gonna come looking for a
a homeless dude with a broken back
look how little they're they want to do
that
that's just weird though like is this
really help it's just weird
oh my God
okay that man is straight on a stretcher
he's going to go from here straight into
the ambulance
it actually has wheels so you can just
wheel them right in
oh
they're like things this will help when
I sleep on this street again tonight did
you bring can I can I say something
yeah
almost never let me let me tell you a
joke
I mean if he
is nice that he's going out and doing
that
is that an interesting observation
um not really
let's not point that out
it's not
all right
oh here's another old lady she has like
a she has a pain cloth in her
mouth you know they bite like wood look
at that she's biting down on wood
um she was probably talking back okay
she looked oh man oh boy
she can drive him that stress response
and that'll drive up that blood pressure
she's scared
oh not the
um
cattle prod oh what the hell it actually
feels like a lot of tension not a board
of wood man
and there's a lot of discomfort so guys
we got 159 over 83 that's more than a it
has more than a 20 point drop after the
adjustment what that's great she started
off very hypertensive at 188 over I
believe 16. is this like a ghost hunting
device just whatever's in the air
blood pressure
all right her blood pressure went down
somehow
she has internal bleeding right that's
that's what happened
all right one more I can't get enough
this is the last one it said it's very
funny buddy I'm with Francisco Francisco
here is not a fan of chiropractors right
not not a fan
that's right about a chronic roll back
problem because of an old herniation is
driving him onto my table now so our job
today is going to be to clean this Lake
and make him a raving fan and help him
understand what's going on in his body
all right
[Music]
oh
you don't know what you don't know until
you know when my adjustments can put you
on then you'll know last guy's not a
doctor man I'm gonna bring you down just
a little bit um
[Music]
all right let's just wrap it up you know
what I mean
things are falling apart we've gone long
enough
oh I'm back
well that's that oh so um I guess if
there's some announcement to say at the
top it's broken again
so this Friday hopefully we'll be uh
doing the tickets to the live very
excited very excited
yeah I've been uh I've been working on
it throughout the show actually actually
and it's um it's looking
pretty good for Friday yeah
Friday let's go I think it's happening
Streamys the steamies
oh we're gonna go all out man we're
gonna embarrass them tell them what a
real award show is dude we gotta have a
YouTube sexiest night on stage oh wow
yeah
yes
and then we can have oh no we can't have
him
YouTube sexiest night that's right
absolutely we'll have a camera on like
you know how you put your face in the
little hole we'll have a camera here and
we'll have a mic on their back
and just continual sounds of people
dying I'm screaming and agony
yeah
thank you guys it's a beautiful Monday
and I'm so glad y'all are here uh
sharing it with us
[Music]
should we do our um sub Drive soon you
feeling that like
that's a this week thing or like a next
week thing you got a thought on that Ian
we got the music playing
you don't talk about right now live
[Music]
all right
here she is
the sexiest Night on YouTube
who should we get out for sexiest night
who do you think represents that better
than anyone hunger FF hunger FF for
reals okay what he'd do a live prolapse
the Dolby Theater they're they're too
classy for that yes
no Fish Fest we got the music probably
no no prolapse of any gun we can't even
show the video you think they're too
classy for that yeah probably not
they're like dude the Oscars are here
plus we already did it it's like the
prolapses are so last year who cares
yeah I'm just think I'm just thinking
aloud yeah
what's sexier than that though
pretty much nothing yo can you send the
article about the Russell investigation
becoming official I wanted to look into
that
that was interesting
hmm
oh wow it's late oh Bobby responded
hold on
okay hold on how do I explain this I'm
gonna send him up a link to Howie's
podcast
I'm not quite sure how's how to explain
it
but the views are good man 150 that way
thank you Ian
[Music]
okay I have a friend
let's let's go up there that's comedian
thanks for watching Everybody give me
Lee we will see you on Wednesday and
Ethan will see you tomorrow for see you
next Tuesday love you take care
cheers my dude
[Music]
thank you